let me know when to open it cuz I'm
going to do the prices right totally
doing that this time uh okay your event
is starting okay it looks like we're
live We Live yep welcome to the weekly
poll with your today's host Rob from
Marvel explained so let's call down our
contestants come on down and seat 204 s
and
Tiffany 48 cuz we have a giant Stadium
today he come on down Dave Howland
yay and in seat three come on down Benny
Potter
me today you're all going to be bidding
on an issue of multiversity how much do
you think that this is actually worth
one
cent Dina
[Laughter]
fire uh I'm gonna say it's 39 no
multiversity I'm gonna say
299 you are both wrong but the closest
without going over is s and Tiffany it
was $4.99 for this going to the
Showcase spin the Giant Wheel man you
guys know way too much about that show
it has been like 20 years since I was
did you never stay home from school
because were you if you were home from
school I was just laid up for two weeks
if anybody who doesn't know who
watching the whole time oh yeah I used
to watch um Days of Our Lives like you
jump in the middle of it and then you
see like one episode and you just get
locked in for the entire days that in
General Hospital yeah and Andy
girlfriend used to watch Days of Our
Lives and I used to record it for her so
oh God I about GFF show The Andy
Griffith Show all right um as you guys
know as usual I'm Benny from Comics
story and that is Rob from Marvel
explain that is Dave from Comics reviews
that that is sh and Tiffany from TV
Little House Tiffany is our special
guest for today's topic and she's from
the show bonus round a really excellent
show that looks at some of the older NES
titles I actually watch your show
[Laughter]
so um by the way you were horrible at Lo
so anyway I am so bad at L I really am I
was watching that and I'm like I don't
remember it being this
hard it's hard it was without a manual
or anything to reference it was pretty
hard like I guess I guess that's the
case I won't let Daniel tell me things
yeah today's usual pre-show we're not
doing reversus today is s's week Sal's
going to give us a topic we're going to
debate it and then we're going to give
you guys s's gonna pick the winner
actually we should let our guest pick
who has the greatest
argument so what is today's debate sou
today's debate is does Batman carry
condoms in his utility
bill because I I feel like the guy
doesn't get nearly as much action as he
probably would as Batman man but he's
always prepared and I think that he is a
great forgive the pun wingman for the
other Robins I think that if Tim Drake
you know and spoiler were gonna like get
down Batman's like I got this i got this
well he does have anything and
everything he needs in that belt yeah he
never really runs out of anything the
question is does he leave real EST
estate like where thermite could be for
rubbers but the point of his belt is
that he has space for everything he
needs right they're all it's it's
basically just an interdimensional well
where he everything it's like Hermione's
bag no really you're gonna compare the
bat condoms to hermion back I mean
ladies and gentlemen I would like to go
on here and say I'm sorry I have to
interrupt here um if we're having a
discussion involving conm and Hermione I
am most satisfied with that discussion
and I feel it needs to continue along
that path because Emma Watson is super
hot so super hot just keep that in the
back of your head and let us continue
so and here's another
thing I'm doing my tweet that that's
counter to the point I just made I
suppose okay and
that's if he does carry
condoms how did Damen Wayne happen that
that's that's my evidence for no he does
not only time we actually do have
evidence no Damien Wayne is not I mean
are we spoiling a book that's like over
five years no I have the video on my
channel everyone here should have
already watched it okay he's not really
his son he's a clone right like he
should have been his son you're spoiling
more recent stuff yeah like technically
he's still technically he's still a son
just technically Batman also has like 30
other clone reject Sons right exactly he
has a leviathan son that's like eight
feet tall and kills his other son I
think that actually there's Aquaman
buried all of the other clones under the
ocean so yeah I think that because the
idea was that like Damian should have
come from the Demon's head storyline
when Batman and Talia first got together
and they first met Rachel ghoul during
the Neil Adams run right that if if if
Damien is had to be a clone in order to
be in existence that means that Batman
was careful and probably did care
condoms and she had to clone him
otherwise she would have been able to
get a a specimen if you actually look at
how she got the sample she definitely
liquored up Batman and had her way now
maybe maybe if we're going into some
very weird areas here but maybe because
you know Batman you would think even
even intoxicated would think to use the
bat condom on his Bat sword but I mean
assuming assuming even intoxicated he
did not have a bat condom for his Bat
sword and toia had him drunk she had his
way with him now let's go ahead and
assume that each one of his kids she had
his way once so she had him drunk for
like 12 hours and just just sit there
just just having fun with the bat sword
over and over and over
so him with no bat sword balloon so it
seems to be said that Benny said that
she had liquored up Batman
yeah didn't drink I thought the idea was
that Batman was a tea
Toler I have no idea about Batman's
drinking habits I would think that a man
that dresses dresses up as like a giant
bat and runs around in the middle of the
night probably has like a liquor problem
yeah you
know you read the actual story he shows
up they just escaped from something and
she's like here have this drink now that
first one was probably rui I'll go ahead
and give him to right I mean come on who
drinks who takes the first sip of a
drink from Talia al goul right even if
you like her she's still your like one
of your main villains and the daughter
of your worst villain so you do not want
excuse me Mr does this smell like
chloroform
yeah another thing I'm going to use as I
guess I would say circumstantial
evidence is whenever there's a storyline
with Catwoman he gets awful excited yeah
so the thing
is he would he be the type of person
that would be prepared for that event oh
yeah well yeah he's prepared for
everything in Earth to he actually has a
child with Catwoman too so what I think
and this is I'm going to make my debate
my debate is he's had accidental
children all over the place we've never
established whether or not Huntress was
intentional or just an accidental all
over the Multiverse
all he just sprayed all over the
Multiverse so I'm going to say since we
have multiple multiple huntresses across
the Multiverse that Batman is not
careful and therefore does not have bat
rubbers for his Bat sword so that that
is where I'm going to stand on this I
think that the I think that the
huntresses Are all uh deliberate and I
think that Damen Wayne's existence in
the fact that he had to be harvested as
opposed to become a natural birth uh I I
think that is evidence enough that he
and especially I think that swinging
around the rooftops and seeing Catwoman
for the first time being like a chick
who's crazy enough to put on a cats suit
and run around like I
am and he went home right that right
then and there my question about
I thought Damian was the natural birth
but then they used the genetic material
of Batman to clone 40 others yeah I
thought the idea was that like he was
that he it was implied that he was
natural but in fact he was a clone but
for Batman it didn't
matter May that's
it all we doing though is Rob is sitting
there going and this is why I don't read
DC this Rob's like what the [__] man May
way Tech just makes terrible condoms so
maybe they just all yeah they're way
Tech condoms so so you're saying that he
does carry them but they all broke
that's your argument it would make sense
I don't know I think if Lucius Fox had
anything to do with those condoms they
are going to be they're also going to do
taxes for you like they're really really
smart and they also may be the reason
why there is clones they do the whole
process down there yeah exactly yeah
they don't get you pregnant they create
a person for you in another lab
somewhere they like 3D print your
genetic material in a
lab that's I think what they do they it
analyzes your genetic material then it
transfers it to a computer it 3D prints
a human and then puts it into a cloning
vessel for you that is that your AR C
because I'm pretty sure we can disprove
that yeah it's probably not really no
maybe so Tiffany our special guest out
of our three arguments I'm stating that
the whole that there is no bad condoms s
is claiming that they 3D print all
humans and Dave is claiming that they
all just broke what do you think
well I I have one question that nobody
touched on does nobody think that Alfred
may or may not have packed him some just
in boom just like that said hey man
carry one in your wallet just in case
just then it's up to him if he's gonna
use it know I would argue that Alfred is
so hellbent against Bruce way being
Batman at this point that he might do
that but he might also poke holes
as like Master Wayne don't forget these
I was like wow you're a lifesaver thanks
a lot alred he's like yeah it be only a
matter of time no no what happened when
had a kid he turned him into a
robin
yeah but that's a very good point and
you got to think about it this way too
could you just picture that right now
Alfred sitting at the Batcave watching
the computer seeing you know Batman
about to get it on the cat momentan he
just kind of rings in the air uh sir
check your lower left pocket exactly I
mean I want to see wallet look for the
ring an episode of like Mory Povich with
like Bruce Wayne like dressed as Batman
and like woman you know and he was like
you said that that Damen Wayne is not
your child that is a lie and
he's we've done the DNA testing and
we've also found these other 50
Leviathan children that you had Aquaman
kill I've got I've got like at least
four huntresses across the Multiverse
that all claim to be your
dog okay multiversity children don't
count I don't know are there any
multiversity yet hold on oh oh no but
issue one we already have Captain carrot
yeah thank
God thank God we got Captain carrot in
there we can't move
forward did anyone happen do anyone has
anyone been reading world's finest when
they actually met Huntress met
Batman I saw a page from that I didn't
read the whole thing she refers to him
for the F that point on as not
Dad okay it's like come on not Dad we
have to go save Superman and he's just
kind of like
uh yeah that's by Jay I think Jay Le
draws that now right yeah pretty cool
but also kind of weird yeah so what
what's the verdict then Tiffany who who
has the best
AR of course I'm like no you could you
be impartial it would ruin the I going
to be impartial as much as I can I mean
I did always grow up believing that
Batman was always prepared but at the
same time there is evidence to prove
that maybe maybe he's not so careful so
I I think it probably is somewhere
between Benny and Dave where it's either
their faulty or he's either just he
doesn't care he's just in the moment
like I don't know maybe he gets laid so
infrequently that like he's just like no
time it's not worth bringing
them if we face it on the amount of
times he's actually been laid in the
comics then yes we're going off of maybe
once per year so yeah he's just he's not
even thinking about it he's like this is
happening this never happens and it's
happening right now that's true
DN [__] this is a guy this is Batman
world's greatest detective smartest guy
in the entire DC Universe probably you
know naturally smart right he is around
247 all the members of the Justice
League and their friends we're talking
people like Power Girl world's greatest
boobs with the boob window we're talking
you know people like Wonder Woman
running around in her bikini and nothing
happens yeah maybe he just doesn't bring
them maybe he's just like it just it's
not going to happen maybe he just feels
it's not worth fumbling with the gloves
in the package there's no time there's
no time and I'm Tak if I'm in the mood
it's now I'm wealthy enough I can I can
absorb this loss especially if he only
gets laid once a
year based upon based upon s's latest
bring up to this argument maybe he does
have multiple children including with
all those fuy girls that he pretends to
be a playboy with and then then there's
just an orphanage of Bruce Wayne
children somewhere like the children of
Bruce wow that how iric that be like a
giant house of morr a series of like the
abandoned children of Bruce Wayne
they're like a the the Wayne Brigade and
they're just like kids of varying ages
and then then you would have the
multiple kids you would have the kids
like you know like the the normal kids
from like the blondes that he sleeps
with and then you would have like
Catwoman's kids in there so like they
would be stealing from the other kids
and there' be like a whole Adventure the
evil Kids versus the good
kids see unwanted
children when you can't tell a real DC
story line from a f DC story line no
here's the kicker though what made what
s just said pretty viable he he prefaced
it with Grant Morrison's yeah no Grant
morr would write a book called The
Unwanted children of Bruce Wayne and it
would freaking sell like Gang Busters if
that book comes out in three months they
stole it from this podcast yes can we
all agree that we are going to go and
file a copyright claim against DC I
think that they would argue technically
fanfiction all right so I can't the
definitive answer has been decided by
Tiffany and I guess from that point
we'll end the pre-show debate now that
everyone's been able to come into here
uh next week we'll probably be doing a
versus or we may be doing a new segment
that we're we're kind of planning out in
which Dave discusses what you should be
buying this month and we discuss if we
agree with him or not I'm not sure
Dave's working it out and I haven't been
paying attention when he talks
so so anyway uh let's go ahead to the
main topic Rob what are we talking about
today man uh we're talking about axis
we're talking about Futures in um Dave
and
assistant we've been wanting to talk
about uh I guess a little bit of
discussion on Inhumans vend Diesel and
so on but not you know just a light
discussion there and I think that one of
the coolest discussions that I think
we're going to have today which is one
of the reasons why we wanted to have
Tiffany on was we wanted a woman's
perspective of the depiction of female
characters in Marvel Comics yep well I
say I think like I said it'll probably
be the coolest discussion I I say we
should discuss him overall with with the
Marvel Comics portrayal that just came
out but that is just the latest in a
slew yeah of over sexualized characters
that is what that is yeah that is not
like groundbreaking brand new we've
never seen a butt crack before right oh
my God women are being objection like
boy this is this is the objectification
of women like we better be careful get
lit on this now before it really gets
out of control yeah yeah no one not the
first time this happen but yeah all
right well then how do you want to kick
it off
man for your show Rob oh I I did my
hosting he's over there vapor
this new juice that just came out called
Cloud science it's called gamma it's
it's uh peach guava mango and cream and
it is amazing oh my God is so good it
tastes that is still nicotine right well
it's got like two and a half I just
discovered last week that medicinal
marijuana is also vaporized oh really I
didn't know that I like sure sure you
didn't we w we get invited on High Times
that's it well I definitely want to kick
off axis and the reason why is because
Marvel has announced that apocalypse is
returning with the axis storyline yeah
but here's the weird thing about axis
what Marvel has said with axis is this
going to be a switch of like everything
that we've seen so far so good guys are
goingon to be bad guys bad guys are
going to be good guys or something like
that I don't know they're going it
sounds really familiar uh Benny don't
you doesn't that sound familiar the idea
of like super villains being superheroes
oh nothing not not like anything I've
heard before like a whole series in
which somebody got trapped in somebody
else's head call Forever Evil elect
Luther took control and is now trying to
join the Justice League that's not what
that is no
okay that's how you guys want to be you
know for the record I'm just gonna go
ahead and say and I'm going to start a
massive flame War over this but for the
for the recorded history for the most
part Marvel has always followed suit on
DC they always follow what DC does they
copy everything down but here's the
kicker because DC did it first because
DC did it first Marvel goes how can we
do it
better true all right fair enough Marvel
does do it better Marvel does it better
that's that's the difference Marvel does
everything better you guys have the
flash we have Quicksilver you know the
flash does not beat Quicksilver I'm
sorry no no sir
noash flash was was going really super
fast and traveling through time before
Quicks over Flash the flash on a weekend
goes to the Prehistoric Age and just
messes things
up the Flash The Flash for vacation goes
through the dimensional barrier I mean
yeah well Quicksilver caused House of M
whereas flash caused flash point so I
think between the two of them flash has
the strike against him um see I don't
really know about
flasho well does that really make the FL
flash point you will do that really Mak
flash
better huh does that really make flash
better or Worse no it makes it worse if
he screws things up no no
no K didn't do House of them Quicks
silver is the Catalyst for House Event
yeah he didn't just travel through time
and alter everything for House Event
yeah that's true flash was the direct
consequence for the flasho situation
hence why it's called
flasho well but even here's a question
about axis I also see trades and I've
seen them all over the place of red
skull as onsl oh my God we were going to
discuss Red Skull has now got the brain
of Professor Xavier and he's now in the
onslaught outfit making him red
Onslaught yeah he could just call
himself Onslaught we don't need to have
all these prefixes like female Deadpool
being Lady Deadpool you could at least
at least it's not like red skull with
Xavier's brain Onslaught man that is
what hell of a log name for a villain
yeah it was actually I picked up uncanny
Avengers and then the last page reveal
of red skull holding Professor X's brain
I was like I'm out this is dude that is
literally where I left too I got to the
end of that and I'm like this no I'm
like that's um to quote Ethan on my show
that's not how that works you can't just
take a brain out that's and give
yourself Powers no you can't do that
it's almost he was eating it like M now
I'm can't take a brain out yeah you
can't take a brain out it's dead he's
dead says who who says you can't just
sence brain out of somebody science says
just remove a brain and gain the powers
of the
brain Sy is a superhero whose exact
power was to do that that well that's
beside the point no was not the fact
remains that Sy was argument the only
thing you could do is argue that like
Red Skull has access to aim super
science and so they kept it alive
somehow see I you know I'm not sure how
I feel about but that still doesn't
understand how he get the powers of it
yeah but I don't all right Onslaught was
better when it was just Magneto hating
humans Xavier being frustrated with
humans and it was one person boom I'm
going to take over the world and then he
got three that was the best version of
onslaught I don't really know if I'm
going to like a Red Skull Onslaught
character well it could be that like
maybe he'll be jockeying for control
like maybe Onslaught will be trying to
take over Red Skull like maybe there'll
be a thing there I don't
know struggle this was a bad idea I
shouldn't taking over your body
Onslaught and Xavier shows up and he's
like you're both are idiots you know and
then and then ons slaugh's like I'm
overpowered a you know they could they
could actually resurrect Professor X
this way they could as Onslaught well
they've already technically resurrected
him as future son of Professor X who
looks exactly like PR Professor Rex yeah
but see here's here's a problem here's a
couple things that I see going on one I
think Marvel is like moving away from
like the old school stuff like we saw
Jean Gray get killed off Jean Gray Gan
gray is probably never going to come
back like people
you are aware of that right no Jean Gray
is not back are you talking about Hope
Summers no I'm about about past Jean
Gray the one that came I'm no I'm not
talking about like the old Jean Gray and
Marvel now showing up the current
generation that's not what I'm talking
about I'm talking about G merge her
Consciousness with the current Jean Gray
and yeah I'm talking about Gan gray
dying an Uncanny X-Men No they're
establishing that this new Jean Gray is
going to become the the old Gan gray but
more powerful she has the old memories
but we have we have we have all that
history with like Jean Gray and the
X-Men and X Factor and all that stuff
yeah and like there's there's all that
history then Gan gray becomes dark
Phoenix and dies so I I don't you know
that's the the Jean Gray that I'm
talking about yeah should be back ah man
it's not gonna be the same no lame
stupid they won't think about it and
they'll just bring her back on a whim
this young Jean Gray is gonna get all
the memories back of the old Jing Gray
she's gonna become that Jing gray again
because we've already implied that old
cyclops has a crush on Young Jun gray
and he she's been getting the memories
of everything everything that happened
for am I the only one reading all new
X-Men yes uh yeah pretty
much showed up I quit I was like oh yeah
it's an X-Men book this is gonna be
stupid it's probably like the best X-Men
book right now it all seriousness what
they're doing is Jean Gray is becoming
more powerful than the old Jan gray ever
was and now because she got put on trial
and because she's been hanging out with
Cyclops and because all the EXP don't
know what's going to happen to her she
has now prettyy much gotten all of the
old Gan Gray's memories back and she's
becoming that Gan gray but like evil and
vindictive and telling everyone to [__]
off sorry censor that Robin post
editing I I stopped I stopped reading
X-Men after Xin Battle of the atam like
that's when I gave up they're gonna give
us back old old drean gray is gonna
basically live on through young drean
gray and that's GNA be their excuses to
why she looks 20-some for the next 50
years of comic books so all right so so
here's my question then have they
explained how it is their conscious
minds are merging into one because I I
thought I was under the impression that
that old Jean Gray was dead and gone
what they're doing right now is now what
they're doing right now is new Jean
Gray's telekinesis powers are so much
more powerful than old Jean Gray that
she's literally like taking all the
memories from everyone else about the
old Jean Gray and learning about old
Jean Gray that way yeah okay that's not
Jean Gray no she's becoming old Jean
Gray in that manner to that you know you
know what that you know what that's like
that's like me painting a picture and
then s coming along and saying I'm
painting a picture it's the same as
Rob's picture because of what other
people are telling me about Rob's
picture it's not the I can say exactly I
can already foresee where this is going
to go what's going to happen is she's
eventually going to become evil because
right now everyone's pretty much yelling
at her and they're trying to put her in
prison for the Phoenix thing and they're
all blaming her for crap the old Jing
gray did so what's going to end up
happening is she's going to become evil
because of that and then the old Jing
Gray's Consciousness or she's going to
finally tap into it is going to come
back and be like no we're not evil yeah
they could always argue that the old
Jean Gray's Consciousness when out into
space or something and then it it's like
been like untethered and now because
they introduced Jean Gray's purest body
into the current timeline it'll find it
and gravitate towards it and latch onto
it and like and they've already
established that these old Xmen are not
the old X-Men it's a different timeline
different dimension totally different
really okay and their powers are now
that that's that's why we still have
them they can't put them back they're
going away now actually did you see
where they're going next no where they
they're putting they're putting the
allnew X X-Men in the Ultimate Universe
God you know the ultimate universe is
like a warehouse for all the [__] they
don't want to deal with yeah the
ultimate X-Men are GNA go to the
ultimate I'm sorry the all new X-Men who
are the displaced original 60s X-Men are
going to be sent to the Ultimate
Universe is it going to be in the
Ultimate Universe or are we still going
to have the same like stories and stuff
going like the same book in The Ultimate
Universe so like they're going to run
into Miles Morales and he's going to
show them around see it's like the
Ultimate Universe is like the punishment
room completely screwed up like go to
the Ultimate Universe theultimate univ
what they established what they've
established at this point though is that
um basically Beast pulled them the old
X-Men yep and he doesn't know where he
got them from they're not they're
they're not the 1960s he went somewhere
else so when he every time he's tried to
put them back he can't and the reason is
because of all these events and altering
of time wherever Beast got them from
doesn't exist anymore that was something
they touched on at the end of Battle of
the atom I thought yeah because like the
whole battle the whole Battle of the
atom the whole that series was so stupid
the whole Battle of the Adam series was
you had basically like three generations
of X-Men you had the old X-Men that were
the ones we first saw like when um
Iceman was like a giant snowman and then
you have like the current generation of
X-Men and then you have the future
generation of X-Men who are all fighting
together and they actually introduced a
character she was really cool and they
didn't do anything with her which I was
so disappointed about but she was able
to manifest like these py monsters or
whatever it was I can't I can't remember
what her name was but they just kind
sure it wasn't Jean Gray CU she's doing
all kinds of crazy [__] no no it wasn't
Jean Gray this was a whired chick but um
they didn't do anything with it but
nonetheless um at the end of that they
were saying like we have to protect the
X-Men like if they die we die and that
was like the whole basis of the thing so
they were basically like the whole story
they were like just stay here they all
just went and fought that's okay
initially what happened is this
um this is totally off our topic but hey
whatever people love tangents do this um
so all new X-Men started up they got
brought into try and convince Cyclops
they discovered that it wasn't going to
work and that now the all new X-Men were
learning stuff about their Futures that
they didn't want to know um in case in
point Jean Gray was learning so much
about her history her powers and
everything that she could do she was now
manifesting all new super powerful
powers like she was blowing Phoenix
gening gr out of the water in in level
power levels this is and this is with no
effort or support from the Phoenix Force
it's just her by she was just turning
into this crazy awesome being so tried
to put them back before he made too much
damage but discovered he couldn't and
then that was when he discovered what
happened now keep in mind the this this
whole thing came out of Avengers versus
X-men when he tried to put them back
it's after Age of Ultron yeah so the
timeline as they've said has been
plucked and everything's rippled
outwards they don't know what's going on
um so then in battle of the atom I
forget who it was but someone died in
the past I want to say the killed off I
think it was Jee gray died it was a
little while ago now someone died and
they discovered that it didn't affect
the future people oh and they were like
what's going on cuz now you're you're my
ancestor we can't put you back and
obviously whatever happens to you
doesn't affect me yeah and so now we've
playing off that and now the book's
gotten a little bit weird Cyclops is now
in space with his dad star jamers he has
his own book he's doing that whole thing
um Bobby Drake is now in love and having
relations with
x23 and Gan Gray is now honing her
powers through Emma Frost am I really
the only one that reads this
apparently I need to get caught up on
after issue nine I was like I'm out I
can't do it it was so like it was I was
having a really great ride and then they
revealed that like Mystique was starting
to manipulate events and manipulate the
younger X-Men and I was like oh yeah
this is an X-Men
book well Xmen books are all about like
that last page reveal and you're like oh
but everything's not going to H it's
just the big thing that's happening now
the big print up protagonist isn't
mystique and them um she pops up still
but the big protagonist is the future
future X-Men so now in the very future
which is what battle of the Adam was we
have the Xavier's son Wolverine's son
they had the they were both the sons
with Mystique so that's the mother of
the both of them um and what's going on
now is they keep going back in time to
prevent their future from happening um
and the way they're doing it is they
keep getting killed destroyed and like
wrecked beyond belief but when that
happens they send themselves a message
in the future saying don't do it that
way again so they go back and do it
again yeah why her X-Men books all about
time
travel x23 is with I always get Iceman
and Angel the names mixed up the real
names she's with Angel not I Angel is is
being in x23 and like I think she
actually was having a relationship with
young Cyclops in the beginning of that
but then he left to go to space with his
dad
yeah I'm looking at Battle of the atam
now and I don't know what character
you're talking oh um he was Beast I
think who died he was killed by a
senel okay I know someone died is it the
the one Sentinels I don't think the one
Sentinels existed at this point in time
no someone died I don't remember who it
was CU they're they're back obviously
whoever it was and this kind of this was
like 14 issues ago now someone died it
was like almost like a a heartbeat just
it was quick how fast it happened and
then they were like why didn't this
affect the future right you know yeah
and then they they determin that it's
actually from an alternate reality right
we don't know well that's what they're
going through now they don't and they
don't know if that's because we've
altered the future like time has been
altered now or if they are from a
completely different dimension in
general and the biggest argument for a
different dimension is how strong Jing
gray is yeah that's funny I I wonder if
Marvel is working on this like if
there's a if there's actually like a
concrete plan because in
Spider-Man the the events of Amazing
Spider-Man are directly influencing the
Universe well yeah well Bend is
supposedly if you if you go back to his
continuity issues okay and by the way we
will get to this is all about access
because honestly I think all new X-Men
are going to affect axis oh yeah which
is what's I think the biggest because
they've been setting up that there's
something huge going to happen with
Xavier and the all new X-Men that's been
the setup in the all new X-Men for a
while now because we have Xavier's son
and they're like you killed my dad
Cyclops I'm here to kill you but if we
alter the timeline and stop you from
getting turning older I'll have my dad I
won't turn into a jackass that kind of a
thing yeah um and so we're it's as much
as people don't I guess aren't reading
all new X-Men that is going to have a
lot to do with the with the with the
axess of it I can tell you right now um
all right let me interrupt you for a
second the issue here with Battle of the
Adam this is what they were talking
about okay um because I was I've been
scrolling through here and trying to
make sense of what was going on no it
was it was Gan gray in the future it was
an alternate version of genan gray in
the future that had that was one that
was part of the future group of the
X-Men and the problem is she was
referring to the Schism the Schism
storyline that was created when
Wolverine fragmented off of the X-Men
and started his own school and like
broke away from Cyclops and that's what
she was referring to was like the future
X-Men like all the future mutants it's
all screwed up because they split the
mutant community in half basically it's
like a mutant version of the Civil War
more or less yeah and that's that's what
she was that's I think that's what she
was referring to but Beast is the one
that died and uh he it was a it was a
younger version of himself that was
killed or maybe the current version of
himself that was killed and the future
version wasn't affected by it he was he
was still there the one with the horns
going out of his head and all yeah is
this one right here uh if real quick we
have a question Christopher this is it
right here and we will discuss that in a
bit after we get out of aess we're going
to discuss Futures and and multiversity
so don't worry so so is convoluted as
this this next event in Marvel is should
should I even
read uh original sin since it's kind of
a
leadup yeah it's short enough and
innocuous enough I think it's it's it's
such a short self-contained kind of
story you could you could read it
without any issue so I mean unless you
want to skip it you could I think well
and this is what Rob and I was talking
about earlier I think original C is
going to directly lead into because
they're setting up access to start as
soon his original s they're not giving a
bre like a breather like they normally
do I don't even think they're connected
I think it's just like they were doing
they were ramping up to original sin and
then they had this axis idea so they
went oh well we're already drawing
original sin so put axis out right after
it like axis is the big one but original
sin had been the big one they were
making bouncy balls and they had like a
thousand variant covers no they had put
money was spent making original sin the
major event and then axis came out and
people were like oh superheroes fighting
bad guys and Onslaught I'm in and they
were like oh that's much more popular
let's just get that out as soon as
possible well like here was the other
thing too like if you look at like at
least from what I can tell with what's
happened in original sin so far like
there's a ton of loose ends like the
most notable of which is Nick Fury you
know and the question we're g to find
out more about that soon there's big
spoil about that already out thanks to
USA Today yeah and I've I've stayed away
from those see what happens but did you
guys speaking of original sin who
everyone here has right issue seven now
right yes I'm currently caught up on
original I'm currently caught up with
everything Tiffany is not reading it but
okay well the reason I bring it up is
because did you guys see like I thought
it was going to be Thor and Loki and
that was going to cause the downfall of
Thor yeah no whatever Nick Fury said the
hammer literally just fell yeah yeah
yeah he couldn't pick up like I was
looking I was like I was like is he not
able to lift his hammer like what in the
hell the coolest thing ever though was
Iron Man reporting that to Captain
America apparently Thor can't pick up
his hammer yeah well he said he said um
Thor's trying to pick up his hammer and
C's like did you say trying yeah did you
say trying one one of my favor parts
that's cool one of my favorite Parts is
when they're all fighting and uh
Spider-Man gets knocked out into space
like everybody's unconscious and
Spider-Man's just like floating in space
he was like anybody can anybody help me
yeah hello didn't he like web something
and pull himself back in I think he did
that but like he was just but it but he
was the only one awake and he's like
guys he shot webbing and grabbed the
eyeballs the watch Nick Fury was like as
like a 90-year-old man
destroying he broke down he was he he
batmann it up he completely broke
everyone down to their basis levels it
was amazing it was I was I was looking
at that I was like like Nick Fury is in
a like he's in a suit and he's got some
weapons but this guy was single-handedly
laying waste to like the Avengers yep I
was like this is ridiculous keeping us
on track with the wrap-up of original
sin I personally think that original sin
is going to you might be right s but I I
I wouldn't put him past them even if
it's a loose link oh yeah into the whole
thing oh you know that the last page
reveal
for Age of Ultron before they bought
Angela was not a big reveal of Angela so
I can definitely see that they end
original sin with a big teaser for axes
like like maybe maybe we learn the
original sin of onslaught or like you
know the original set of red skull is
that he had Onslaught this whole time or
like ni knew this this whole time or
Professor X never really got rid of
onslaught yeah yeah see that's that's
something I'm hoping that we get
something really cool because I'll be
honest with you guys with the exception
of a couple things a couple reveals like
Nick Fury actually being old that the
orb was actually the one that shot The
Watcher like but didn't kill him didn't
kill him he just blew the blew like half
his head off you know I'm I've been
pretty much let down I know I have too
by Oral to be the coolest part of this
original sin event has been the tians
not the event the event is cool and all
I'm reading it but I've liked the reveal
of silk more I've liked the reveal of
Thor's sister more I liked the Hulk and
Iron Man story more like the stuff that
came out of original sin is what I liked
more than original sin I think original
sin is cool and we have to have that
otherwise the story makes no sense as to
why all this other crap happen yeah but
I think Sil sucks but I like everything
else yeah I'm just kind of like another
one like there's nothing like I'm more
looking forward to finding out the end
of the Thor and Loki story and what's
going to happen with silk than I am
finding out in original Cate no I'm more
I've seen a lot of people saying that
about Thor and Loki a lot of people are
curious people love that book it's great
yeah the dude the Iron Man and Hulk
thing that was a great reveal at the
ending oh my god did you guys finish
that whole five parter no I've only
heard about it but I did not read the
end yet so and this this is this this is
a tangent from axis because this isn't
going to TI in axis at all it wraps up
but the whole concept is the what the
because this is also where they reveal
that what happened with original sin was
everybody else learned everybody else's
memories yeah that's how it happened so
Bruce Boehner saw Tony Stark's memories
of Tony Stark messing with the gamma so
he assumed that Tony Stark did this he's
the one that created the whole problem
yep um but what we find out on Tony
Stark's side is that Bruce only saw part
of it Tony Stark had fixed the bomb cuz
Bruce had made it so much shielding the
blast would have wiped out Nevada or
something like that and the final moment
Tony's like because he doesn't want
Bruce to feel bad you find out that Tony
even sent an email warning Bruce Banner
about it but Tony got Bruce Banner's
memory and Bruce Banner said screw Stark
I don't even need his advice and deleted
the email oh there you go so if he had
gotten Tony Stark's email he wouldn't be
the Hulk that's cool see yeah see I
never I I didn't finish that part of it
I was a little hesitant I was in all
honesty like I was kind of wrapped up to
see what was going to happen with Nick
Fury and in all honesty I thought that
was a really cool reveal I thought it
was a cool reveal to say that like Nick
Fury's been old this whole time and he's
just been hiding on the moon like that
was interesting you know now my question
my my question is like I think we asked
this question before is who's gonna take
over the role for Nick Fury because
that's that he made I think I think
it'll be Punisher I think they're
actually I agree with what Rob I agree
with Rob said earlier in this whole
series he thinks it's going to be a
total spin-off
book yeah I could totally see a spin-off
book of everyone competing for it or
there being a whole Nick Fury team yeah
something I mean it'd be a cool way to
see The Punisher because honestly aside
from the Punisher just like arbitrarily
shooting people yeah he doesn't work in
the Marvel Universe anymore he just
doesn't yeah there's really no need for
him he was cool in the 90s when it was
like let's just have a GU kill people
and do stuff he would eventually be like
I got to kill the Kingpin and people
like you can't kill the Kingpin we sell
Kingpin books and it's like we sell
kingp books so yeah I mean like I would
love to see Punisher be the man on the
wall that'd be so cool that would be
awesome are any of you guys reading
uncanny Avengers because I know that is
also directly correlated with with ACC
well I've heard that's a bad lot time
travel and insanity and I I I just
haven't had a chance to pick it up and
read it I heard they do something like
they send them they send them like up to
like 30,000 years into the future or
something no that's Avengers that's
Avengers world yeah no that's not
avengers world that's Avengers unless
unless unless Avengers world is now
picking up off of that Avengers because
of versin sin they're project they're
being thrown into the future just
randomly arbitrarily the time gem from
the INF right so I actually got so far
as the future of 30,000 years in the
future Captain America met with Franklin
Richards and we do discover that
Franklin Richards is he's just infinite
he's allmighty yeah and we also get a
tree version of group see this is what
happens when you have a YouTube channel
where you explain Marvel Comics and
you're not explaining current stuff like
all you have time to read is like God
loves man
kills like old comics from like 1980s
and you on the stuff yeah we need like
we need another Channel that's just
about that's just like what what the
Marvel it's a collaboration Channel I
need I need to do that like I told Benny
what I wanted to do is do um like after
I do Infinity Gauntlet I want to do Age
of Ultron and then just like start
moving forward and periodically like
touch back on old stuff but I wanted to
get into like current events the problem
is it's stupid convoluted dealing with
like current stuff oh yeah Heaven man
why I focus more on the future stuff
than the past stuff the past stuff is
cool I like the past stuff I've read a
lot of the past stuff but the fact of
the matter is 90% of the stuff you've
covered and the stuff that I've read is
out the window now as far as Comics go
yeah yeah everyone everyone keep asking
me to do blackest Knight and blackest KN
would be great to do but blackest Knight
doesn't matter at all yeah yeah long
gone that's pretty much how Marvel
launched it like Marvel Marvel said okay
House of M Civil War secret Invasion and
then just rebooted everything yep like
okay they just they just reset the
typewriter it was yeah pretty much
Gabriel thinks that Bucky was going to
become the man on the wall um
probably uh someone's saying that Kenji
thinks that Captain will be since Falcon
is now the new captain oh yeah that is a
good
point I don't think so though because
some of the stuff that Nick Fury did was
pretty damn
Shady have a hard timeing Captain
America would do that unless this is how
they're going to develop his character
further but it's Captain America man
like at the end of the day Captain
America is a guy that just won't kill
people that's is a good man matter how
you um there's also um what was this uh
Christopher is not a fan of silk some
people aren't um they don't like how
off-the-wall silk gets she's kind of
crazy and all over the place yeah and so
far I want to see where they go with it
but yeah I just like like all right they
like I trust them I guess I'm sure
they'll just BL away hold on real quick
Gabriel thinks that Rob reads current
books because he said uh I thought you
did the Franklin Richards video
specifically because of that issue of
the Avengers where we see in 30,000
years in the future I mean yeah but
here's here's the pro like that was
simply just a byproduct of the fact that
if we're going to explain Franklin
Richards we have to have some context
when we say Franklin Richards make
galatis as heral because if I just said
Franklin Richards makes galatis as heral
and then move on to the next thing you
guys are like wait what who what wait
that's pretty cool talk about that yeah
talk about that some more like tell me
why celestials from an alternate reality
vading like the current reality like
help me understand what the hell is
going on here and that's that's why it's
so crazy and convoluted because half the
story of Franklin Richard in the future
takes place in the Fantastic 4 the other
half takes place in future foundation
and it just goes you know yep but I will
say this though like Hickman is amazing
when it comes to doing Fantastic Four
stories like I've never read a Hickman
part like a like any part of Hickman's
run and if I had more money in my weekly
budget I'd be getting that one I had to
turn it down again today I was there and
I'm like looking at the Fantastic 4 book
and and I was like I can't afford it I
got a stack of books it can now isn't it
like over to get that
Omnibus it's ki's asking if anybody read
new Avengers 23 I have it right here but
I think I'm the only one reading the
incursion story line I saw what h i i i
see everybody's ramping up because they
can't stop it like it looks like the the
last incursions coming right well the
story has to end eventually I they they
have fought Justice League now you can't
just go anywhere from here what are you
g to fight you see did you read uh
multiversity no it's sitting right here
I hav't ready yet the because the
Avengers are in it ah really BR Morrison
Hickman's like he he he he sticks a
middle finger at Hickman for putting the
Justice League in New Avengers in there
because they destroyed the Justice
League I know I mean like you got you
got tala you got namore like that alone
you're
effed so okay um I'm going through the
comments again before we move over
though so do we have anything else to
really to go over about axis I mean we
see red skull on slau we have theories
about coming out
original yeah I'm honestly I'm hoping
that the core storyline for this is as
big as the infinity storyline yeah
that's what I'm kind of hoping for I
don't original sin I feel like I don't
know it was more of a like a giant wh if
storyline like they just took they took
the concepts of wh if that did well and
they like what if we put in the real
world what if Spider-Man had another
spider what if Iron Man what you know
was the reason for Bruce Banner what if
Thor had had a sister let's put that in
the main universe that's that's what it
feels like to me well I mean depending
on what they decide to do with axis like
I feel like this could be like a leadup
to actors like this this whole thing
this whole original S Series could just
be called like you know Axis leadup or
something like that because again like
there's so many Loose Ends assuming that
they close out Nick Fury like we have
issue number s closes out with all these
Watchers watching what's going on fury
on the mo and so it's they're not going
to be happy with that I can guarantee
you they're not I I agree but the
question is like what what are they
going to do and I have a feeling like
they're not going to be able to close
every single thing that's happened so
far in original sent out in one issue
that's just not GNA happen so I do it
like Infinity leave Lo a bunch of books
we were we were talking about this
earlier if they do that would be classic
Marvel yeah it would be it would just it
would I mean basically like you'd be
reading the comic you would be like well
this happen and then this happens and
then these things happen and then we're
done thanks for reading guys it's that's
I like that's what happens when I'm
explaining these books like especially
the most recent ones to the guys and I'm
like this is what happened and they're
like well what next I'm like nothing
yeah like well this then this next book
and they're like
oh like it's very anticlimactic yeah a
lot a lot of comic book story lines are
that way though they'll be anti-climatic
they'll just be like and we're done yeah
that's enough hit hit the hit the off
button they build to these massive
things that and close out so maybe
original sin will be the be the flip on
that maybe it'll change it around um
axis I'm having a big like I think the
problem with original sin is we didn't
have a core bad guy no we had nothing
being ramped up we had nobody prepping
for things we just had everybody being
like Oh my God and the bad guys who were
in it were ineffectual and like third
tier yeah like the superior foes of
Spider-Man are more well-known and more
topical than the characters that showed
up in original sin and that's one of the
things like see one one of the things
I'm most excited about with axis like I
said is that apocalypse is coming back
and to me this is a huge thing because
we had apocalypse killed whatever it was
he came back as a kid and the whole like
Marvel kind of did this whole thing the
same thing they did with Hope Summer is
like well apocalypse could come back to
be a really good guy and do some good
stuff or you could be like a really bad
guy and be like what he was before but
worse and it's like okay I mean and I'm
I'm hoping they pick the side because
the way they're the way it's being
talked about like he's going to be a
villain yeah and so well here's my
question for as a bad guy is it
apocalypse or is it kid apocalypse no
it's supposed to be like a like
apocalypse like the grown adult
apocalypse like because kid apocalypse
just teamed up with Deadpool again and
helped him like a full-blown good guy
not even Shady at all yeah but also keep
also keep in mind though I mean it it
may very well be that it turns out to be
kid apocalypse but keep in mind like kid
apocalypse is demonstrating has
demonstrated on several occasions the
mindset that the old apocalypse had of
survival the fittest he's demonstrated
his powers on multiple occasions so
you're
talking he would he would team up with
Deadpool because Deadpool is the only
one who wouldn't kill him yeah right I
no yeah I forget his name but yeah he's
friends with Deadpool Deadpool had to
save his daughter his da he like threw
his daughter out the window but like he
sent a message to kid apocalypse help me
come and rescue my daughter yeah and he
showed up and he's like hey I got her
here you
go yeah what's going on buddy how you
been you been good you you good you good
how's the kid oh I just saved her right
here she
is but that's that's what I'm curious
about is I'm I'm really wanted to see
like a return of the Evil apocalypse but
the question is like they said he's
supposed to appear in issue number four
so the question is how big of a role is
he going to play because whenever you
saw Apocalypse in the comics it was
always like some stuff happens over here
but an apocalypse is like masterminding
everything it would be cool if we got to
see I like this is just be me being a
nerd I would like to see the onslaught
Red Skull fight a yes that's exactly and
I think that's what it's going to lead I
think that's why he's going to appear in
Issue four he's going to show up and
Onslaught Red Skull is going be like M
punch
and be cool it was be cool and ba well
again like it depends on what kind of
power Onslaught has because if you
remember during the onslaught series
like with Magneto Xavier Onslaught like
apocalypse couldn't stop him he was
except then he turned into thought and
that was lame yeah he he
did he turned into Pure Energy yeah so I
I don't know I mean that that was the
whole thing like The Watcher showed up
and The Watcher was like like you need
to get in there and do something because
if you don't like he's going to kill
everybody else and then kill you y jump
in and be a vessel for him and you're
ready for it that was weird yeah it's a
weird ending I I don't I don't know I'm
just kind of curious to see how it all
how it's all going to go down but either
way like I'm I'm pretty excited for axis
like I'm pretty interested to see where
it leads well let me ask you this then
because and have you been reading the
incursion story line Rob no okay s has
do you think the incursions are going to
be a like because we have two we have a
couple big story lines happening in the
universe right now yeah I mean there's
the one where uh Captain America went to
the Future came back
and now we're going to see what happens
with that we have the incursions
happening over at New Avengers um
original sin the whole Nick Fury thing's
happening um do you think that the
incursions will have anything to do with
access event
no that's GNA all by itself I think the
incursions are like will be on the
undercurrent I think they'll be able to
blame stuff that happens on the
incursions but I think the incursions
are are Hickman's own plan I don't think
that I think ax is another thing I think
that they're just ax is a cool story
they're going to do that's going to like
kind of clean up or like that'll save
some time until the incursion story gets
wound up I I think we're going to get
another Infinity type story out of the
incursions that makes sense though if
the incursions is part of Hickman's run
because again touching back on the
Fantastic Four Future Foundation was a
standalone series like that was just
like it didn't involve anybody else it
was just you know just hi it was just
the Fantastic Force so I mean I wouldn't
be surprised if that was the case where
this whole thing with incursions is just
like a standalone series like Marvel
Knights or something where yeah it just
only involves those particular
superheroes but doesn't tie into
anything else yeah yeah but the pro the
problem with the incursion St line of
New Avengers is I think it's going to be
needed for the the axis thing at least
to the extent of oh here's the members
of the Illuminati the smartest guys and
the biggest characters in the Marvel
Universe they have to at least show up
for 5 seconds and be like sorry we're
busy with other things I'll talk to you
later I think they're going
to reveal the Illuminati at the end of
the of this and I think that that's
what's going to lead I think that in
that regard that'll what that's what's
going to lead into like the heroes being
villains and the villains being Heroes
kind of thing like the you're gonna be
like that's why you saw like Doctor
Strange go like Wong am I a good man and
Wong's like no you are not no not after
what you just did like a monster you you
just absorb The Souls of all monsters
like and I think that that's going to be
a big like a big kick in the ass for
like the superhero Community I think
they're going to be like disillusioned I
think they're going to be
disenfranchised with the whole oh
another one of those things of we put
all our faith in these guys the only one
we can trust is going to be Captain
America or the only way we can trust is
the Red Skull or
some I mean whoever well how about this
throwing this out the wall well real
quick Dave Hold on so encourages make
all of our big guys bad guys Red Skull
comes out and says I'm actually
Professor Xavier I took over his body
I'm in control yeah I mean we've all
seen that when Xavier goes when when
Xavier goes arai like he gets really
really bad yeah he is but if he comes
forward he's actually Xavier yeah every
I think everyone would get behind him
until he proves he's also
evil yeah would it would it make sense
that maybe one of the other worlds that
happens to to
be what incurring or colliding into our
world has some sort of countermeasure
and that world has like the villains as
the good guys and they come over and
fight no we've already done that they
encourage have already happened that way
yeah we've already seen the flip side
we've already seen like I think there
was the Marvel Zombies Universe
incursion at one point oh that's we've
already had the Justice League they've
already seen multiple worlds that have
died they they would they the Marvel
zombies one they found like a desolate
world that already destroyed itself and
I think it was implied that it was the
Marvel Zombies Universe oh that's cool
oh yeah but they I mean they've played
on that several times like there was a
point the Marvel zombiie storyline when
um Dr Doom made Reed Richard switch
Minds with him and in order for Dr Doom
to effectively like allow the zombies to
be defeated on that Earth right and then
like at the end like he's to switches
Minds back because he's just like I
can't do this to
you I too easy I know the Illuminati in
the past have done some pretty shady
things like when they shot you know the
Hulk in into the you know that that
gladiator planet that yeah you know
world but he ended up off course yeah he
smashed the control the the guidance
system so he wound up in world
yeah so like I know they've done some
pretty shady things in the past but this
seems like extreme oh yeah oh no the
that's why I can't watch that's why I
can't read it because like they're all
they're all monsters like they're all
like yeah Captain America was the only
that though I
like it's cool but it's also frustrating
that's why it was such a great moment no
what I like about it is it is it shows
how far they're really willing to go
right where are they willing to go yeah
yeah but see like I I feel like well
that's always been a question in comic
books though yeah how you know if
someone's destroying the world will
Superman finally kill somebody you know
if if the the Hydra takes over it starts
killing people everyone will Captain
America actually shoot someone and if
we're going to lose our entire universe
will some of the Pinnacles of the good
guy side of the the superheroes turn
villain answer is yes but the writers
could have literally done anything else
with it like those questions wouldn't
come up if they just said no they're
going to find some way with with or
something to close no but that's what we
always expect and that's what they've
tried that that's what this whole book
is about them trying to find that and
when they killed the Justice League that
was it like they were like we've tried
everything there is no answer we've used
the infinity gems we've tried technology
our only answer now is to put a bomb on
your planet yep that's but there's no
coming back from that you can't I I
don't want to read Adventures about
these evil people who were will who did
like if they can't find a solution then
how are they superheroes right they're
not if Superman they're just they're
just that's the thing that's the thing
with Marvel Marvel's always on the human
level and as normal humans if our rules
are colliding the four of us would
probably go right to the bomb and not
try the other things that's true and
like that's like this is this is the
thing like that's why Man of Steel sucks
because like if Superman were like like
if he murders somebody that's like the
easy way out like we want to watch super
we want to read superheroes because
they're better than us because they can
arrive at a solution that is not what we
would do that's what DC is DC will
always have the answer DC will never
they don't have the answer they
freaking well no but what I'm saying is
DC like Marvel's always been grounded
Marvel's like we can't find the answer
we need to come up with the extreme DC
would have come up with some crazy thing
like resetting the entire universe would
that would have been your superhero
response right but you're seeing where
Marvel's going Marvel will eventually
have to reset in order for us to care
about Reed Richards as a person like or
we just pull him from the past when he
was that's I mean like oh just pull the
good Reed Richards back it's fine kill
that evil one like but see here's the
thing about Reed Richards like I've
never really cared about Reed Richards
right like I did before but the problem
is Reed Richards is is that no matter
what the conflict that's going on
Reed Richard is just like I need to fix
this for
science science the entire time he will
be a dick everybody else as long as he
can have his work yeah yeah but the
thing the problem with Reed Richards is
we've proven time and time again in
multiple other storylines that he will
turn evil that he will cross that line
Marvel zombie storyline even though it's
a wh if one of the first scientist to
turn evil is Reed Richards yeah you know
there there's multiple other what if
time on where he's the first guy that's
like it's for the greater good whatever
I'll man like during the during
Hickman's run of the Fantastic 4 when
you had the Council of reeds every
single version of Reed Richards that was
part of the Council of reeds had taken
Dr Doom and like lobotomized him they
had they had a giant room down in the
basement of like the Council of reeds
where all you had were like all these
Dooms that would just like repeat their
names that's all they knew how to say
yeah it was really screwed up yeah it
was really really messed up it was
that's always been Reed's character and
Doctor Strange has always been on the
verge he's always been on the borderline
tala's always been talking to evil
spirits who tell him to go do whatever
is
necessary a bad guy and Neymar has
always been the bad guy always yep Ney
Neymar's been the anti-hero but he usly
always fought on the side of good the
only exception you could make to this
would be like maybe Avengers versus
X-men where he's one of the Phoenix
five that even that's questionable like
I mean how is that questionable because
look look at what they did like look at
what they did all right like they they
totally revamped Utopia like it was it
was literally a Utopia like they made
the world better overall and then people
were still fighting against them now the
whole reason it was stupid they were
like we just want Hope Summers I mean it
was it was dumb like the whole
motivation behind it was dumb but in the
end like they were still attacking the
Phoenix 5 but the the fear was that like
I think Scarlet Witch had pointed out
that in the end like it was going to
lead to the destruction of everything
which is why she was like something
needs to be done but until that played
out like you couldn't really they were
bad guys they were just you know they
were trying no but the problem the
problem with Neymar has always been
neyar and like he's just proven in the
New Avengers book will always be the
first guy to cross that line exactly
he's always like well I'm a he is always
the first re Richard will always follow
suit pretty quickly afterwards Doctor
Strange is always like M damic magic I
like you oh I like how you taste oh but
I'm so addicted no no no you're still
dirty that's that's what I hate about uh
about Doctor Strange like he's such a
powerful character and it's like
Marvel's like we don't know what to do
with this guy like I mean he's here and
we could do some stuff but like what do
we do and so basically like Doctor
Strange just kind of hangs out and says
like I'm just going to be an enigma this
entire time and then show up at the very
end and just be like you know what you
should do and he was wul underused in
Adventures but like he's such a powerful
character though like what could you
really do with him I mean even after he
was reccon and his power was toned down
he was still really powerful yeah so
well okay in all honesty is that
technically our problem with the Hulk
like the reason the Hulk doesn't ever do
well in his own book is he's so powerful
to put him up against stuff you need to
give him superpowered cybernetically
enhanced Russian bears in space where he
has no gravity like that that's the
answer to make the Hulk an actual give
him a viable enemy it's like no no I
mean like when you were talking about um
the different variations different
colors of the Hulk and like Bruce Banner
and the Bruce Banner Hulk relationship
like I mean you were right like during
Onslaught when Gan gray like ripped
their minds in half and separated the
two of them like the Hulk was just pure
Unstoppable Force he was the only person
who could punch a hole in ons
yeah I mean that's that's one of the
things I like about the Hulk is like
he's he's a great character and he's
really really powerful but he just wants
to be left alone like 99% of the time
right yeah so you like the screen the
picture I put in the Hulk video holding
the
bunnies buny
scared I saw that I was like that's cool
but but I mean even then like the Hulk
is the hul is cool like I was talking
about the century I don't know if it was
something that I touched over or not but
like during the the Marvel Knights run
when this when the uh the void shows up
like the Hulk is scared and the centy
Tells Hulk like I know you're scared you
know but like we have to fight the senty
and the Hulk is like I mean if we have
to like I don't really want to you know
but if we have to fight the void then I
guess we will but you know it was it was
cool to see that element of the
character but I I usually like Hulk
because sure he's overpowered sure he's
pretty strong but he's got attributes of
his character that help to offset that
so well he right now he's smart again
and I think they're setting that up for
the axess event yeah I don't I don't the
way the way Iron Man versus X-Men Works
um Iron Man gives him the extremis which
allows Hulk to be intelligent see I
don't I don't like I don't like smart
Hulk like I like I think the whole
extremist thing was a terrible idea
anyway but um the whole at least they're
trying to do something with it they're
not just like I'll brush that under the
rug exem I'm pretty used to like smart
Hulk has always been kind of like a
character that I'm used to because I'm
always like used to Peter David's like
Bruce Banner's brain and Hulk's body
like the Savage dragon Hulk that he was
that Eric Larson used to draw like
that's the one I'm used to like it was
see I don't and I liked it when Hulk was
smart and banner was an insane evil guy
trying to kill him that was like I know
I know most Hulk fans hate that series
but that was like the most unique idea
I've ever seen with the Hulk that's true
um what was this I can't remember the
name of the story line it was the one
with h Tony Stark where like the whole
extremist thing and like his suit became
a part of his physical body yeah I think
it was called extremist was it called
extremist okay I can remember it was I
thought it was called something else
yeah I thought it was called Iron Man 3
I
couldn't all right well now been going
for about 45 minutes on the Marvel
topics and making poor Tiffany suffer
and listen to us this whole time I I
enjoy it i' I've been I'm I'm enjoying
she's been she's been part of this
podcast for seven n years don't seem
like we're boring you but no I'm just
taking it all in because you know what
usually how I end up reading story arcs
is I listen to him talking about them
and the more excited he gets about the
more I have to read it like the reason I
read the CT of owls is because he was
like this is amazing and he wouldn't
stop talking I'm like all right I got to
do story in a while that
was Rob needs to
read I agree it starts it starts with
court of owls Into the Night of owls
it's an awesome AR yeah that would be a
really good spot for you to start Rob
well it's new 52 number one like it's
new 52 Batman one yeah it starts Batman
all and it goes all the way up to like
Batman 15 I think so you can get two
books and that's it if you want to um
but the reason since before we go over
to DC and discuss what we foresee
happening at future future end and how
we feel about a fiveyear jump in our
comic series um I figured that Marvel
would be a great time to talk about the
current Spiderwoman image oh my God and
the reason why we so that we were're not
just sitting here for three hours with
her just sitting there staring at
us um so for those of you not tracking
the issue and Rob you're going to have
to put it into the the thing or L um
they just released what uh we've just
got the announcement that there is a new
Spider Woman comic coming out it's going
to be uh Jessica Drew and silk probably
something like Jessica Drew teaching
silk how to be a superhero and blah blah
blah silk is the new spider girl that's
in the Spider-Man book we discovered her
from original sin um now what's going on
is the normal cover looks great great
artwork and everything the variant cover
has been proven to be literally a naked
girl that they just colored in a costume
on yeah yeah literally goes It goes up
so far up her butt crack it's not like
that's not even physically possible it's
not even up anything it's just paint
it's like they just body painted her um
now obviously this is causing a huge
upward because we already have an issue
with an over sexualization of female
characters in comic books if you don't
believe me look what happened when they
tried to get rid of the boob window for
a power girl that lasted like 50 issues
and then conveniently she found the old
costume with the boob window I mean I'm
surprised people got so upset that like
we didn't like people were like whoa we
took away the boob
window that was the biggest I was like
that too I'm like the boob window was
cool and all but I'm also not 12 so yeah
they're they're animated characters guys
they're they're Illustrated they're not
they're not real I didn't like the not
because of the boob window lcking but
because the giant p over the other boob
was just lame it was yeah Power Girl
well that's the thing like with the
Powergirl redesign like give me a better
costume then right I'm fine if you get
rid of one of her trademarks that's fine
I mean yeah all right if you guys want
to see the the video or see that image
to or the website that I posted you guys
will have to like refresh and look in
the description because I can't post it
in the comments you can't post in the
chat that's that's stupid if you just
Google uh Spiderwoman number one and
Spiderwoman number one very Milo man
Mana yeah
Manara so basically the big rundown is
and this is where we wanted to Tiffany's
opinion because this is not the first
time
an overly sexualized video video game
video game and comic book that anyway it
doesn't matter but it's not the first
time that this has happened and not the
first time he made headlines which is on
my reaction why is this making headlines
this happens like every other
month I guarantee you going through my
books this week I can find a cover with
an over sexualized girl hold on I I give
me two seconds I will find something I
just bought that does that that is that
is doing a very improper deadpol is a
very good one yeah we can go with
that I mean I think that one of the
reasons why this is being so hyped up
though is because it's one thing to
where you have like over sexualized
characters that are dressed a certain
way is another like when you have an
over sexualized character that plays to
that over sexuality and that's what
that's what the variant comic seems to
do like you've got like Miss Marvel
who's dressed in a really skimpy outfit
you've got other characters here and
there who do the same thing but then
you've got this image of spider girl
that's kind of over sexualized isn't
it I mean yeah you're talking about like
over sexualized female features yeah
it's a little gratuitous it's not even
no look
here's let's let her speak it's explain
to us explain to us from a woman's
perspective all right I understand first
of all that most of these characters
were designed at a time where women were
100% sexualized like they weren't
necessarily even on the same level as
men so when you look back at them and
when you look at their development over
time you have to take that into account
you have to and you also have to take
into account that sex sells it you put a
woman like that on your cover it's
probably going to sell the difference
between this image I think and most of
the images that you see in a comic book
store is this isn't
sexuality at all this is this is
gratuitous to some degree and this is
coming from someone I read Saga but the
gratuitous sex in that is for the
purpose of the story she is in a
submissive pose she is essentially naked
and she is supposed to be the woman that
we're buying this comic book for and
she's supposed to be an empowering
strong woman nope like couldn't further
from The Mark and I think that's really
where people should have the issue with
this is don't put her in a pose like
this I understand she's an a spider
character and they do that but you can't
you can't put that on your cover and
expect me to believe that this person is
is powerful or empowering or strong yeah
doesn't come across like that and see
it's interesting that you talk about
that because if you look at Marvel Now
with Miss Marvel issue number one like
she's she's like she's an over
sexualized character but she's got like
this strong dominant pose on the the
cover of the yeah there's absolutely
nothing wrong with an over sexualized
character it happens both ways like I
but first want to admit it I don't
expect to see a guy who has a Clark
Kenan or Superman you know physique
walking down the street but it's nice to
look at in a comic book however that's
not all that he is right just most of
the like oftentimes the issue with an
over sexualized woman is the fact that
they're like that's all that she is if
you put a strong personality or an
interesting personality behind that I
don't care I think that's why like
Amanda Connor and Jimmy pal mi's
original Powergirl book was like popular
and successful like it it got to you get
to you get a little bit of cheesecake
with Amanda Connor's very like specific
art style but it also told a fun story
and it made it really it really I think
served the power girl character um so it
was less you took a gratuitous or a
potentially gratuitous character and
design and then turned it into something
fun as opposed to well the the the power
girl a personally I hate what they've
done with her in the New 52
the the original run was great it really
was and like you said there was there
was those scenes in there I remember in
particular like one issue was almost
entirely a shower scene with her in a
towel um that's because I'm a guy it
stays pretty prominent in your brain
when you see a whole issue with the girl
in the towel but she was also in charge
of her company she was also a very
strong woman she you know and part of
the problem I have with the new the new
book that she's in is the fact that
she's now been backgrounded to what
Huntress is doing and she's like oh look
she's really strong and oh look she's
making all the inventions and she just
wants to go home what's Huntress doing
you know yeah um but I think the problem
with the Spiderwoman this and I mean I
don't know if you've been reading the
current stuff Tiffany or not but
personally she doesn't make a lot of
appearance already but every time she
does she's always been that strong
character I you know um one partic scene
in particular I remember when she had to
team up with the Hulk yeah one of her
powers is pheromones and she made the
Hulk her [__] that's what she did that
was the whole point Hulk make me a
sandwich Hulk I'm cold and it was like
this is a a cool character what what she
can do to the Hulk you know and Hulk's
like spider lady like you know yeah the
last I I really read of her was way back
when she was on New Avengers and you
know I like the character um but I'm
telling you right now if I walked into a
comic book store and I saw that I
wouldn't even bother to pick it up
because I'd be like I don't I don't know
what this is but it does not appeal to
me yeah and again I I think personally
that the female form and the male form
are are beautiful and they're amazing
and like being from an arts background
there have been plenty of opportunities
for me to draw naked people um and over
time obviously in every uh various
historical art historical movement you
will always see the idealized version of
male and female whether whatever that be
at the time so you're going to see that
and we're going to see that now and
that's what people want to see and they
want to look at it but something like
this it's it's literally it's the pose
and it's the feeling of it and I
understand that this artist is an older
man um I believe yeah 69 68 somewhere in
there and that excuse works I mean the
same thing for why people allow Adam
Hughes beautiful artwork but every piece
of Adam Hugh's art you're like he just
item he just itemized a woman on his on
his cover you know look at Catwoman oh
she's
so right right and like I'm not saying
that it's a a it's an excuse for him to
do that in his in his private art
collection like that's what he has and
that's what he wants to do I I I don't
think it's an excuse for Marvel and I I
really think that Marvel editorial
should have taken a look at this and and
just taken a step back and thought to
themselves how does this portray us and
what we think about are a a kind of
Flagship female character who's supposed
to be coming out and giving us another
Edge when you're facing an Amazonian you
know like Wonder Woman I mean the idea
of the Amazon themselves is so
empowering for women and sometimes they
nail it with her and sometimes they
don't yeah and like currently with
azarel's Wonder Woman book I like they
went from she had long pants to she's
wearing her bikini bottom again but
like but even then which did you prefer
on that one honest question really I
feel like it's understated like I I've
read a bunch I read a couple issues of
Wonder Woman Like the most recent run
and it's that's like really not
important no it isn't I think for me the
the issue I have with that going from
the pants to the Bikini Bottom has
nothing to do with how she looks it's
necessarily the reason they made the the
switch over it was just because people
were responding to the character as much
and that makes me sad to some degree
like that they're not necessarily there
just like even to get past the the pants
if you just want to have her in the
Bikini bombs just put her in it I don't
care she looks great in them I think she
looks like what most women wish she
could look like in them so go for it but
don't backpedal just don't backpedal so
so basically you're saying that because
the the public didn't agree with the
long pants they they just back pedal on
and that's what upsets you not so much
the shift back yeah exactly look like
again understand it sex cells that's why
we have half naked men and women selling
overly priced clothing to us because
when we look at that we're like man I
want to look like that I want to you
know I want to have that because look at
how it looks on them so I want to look
like them so when you go into the the
comic book store and you see you know
like zatana you know in her like deep
veed you know corset top on the cover
it's like I'm immediately drawn to that
even as a woman I'm like I'm kind of
drawn to that want to take a look at it
when I see this this water this spider
girl cover I don't want anything to do
with that not only do I not want to look
like that but I don't ever want to be
put in a position like that yes well
here's here's a question that I would
ask though like to play deil's advocate
here for a second so you talk about how
sex sells so the question is if sex
sells and the purpose of Marvel is to
sell a product could you really argue
that they're wrong to take this step
well I think in terms of if you're look
looking at the any publicity is good
publicity then no this was not a mistake
but I don't think that this is
necessarily the same sexuality that they
tend to go after this someone in the
comments mentioned that this is
borderline pornographic and and it is to
some degree um it's not very good
pornography to begin with but I
mean I just I
agree yeah like you look at um like Greg
land and how he traces women in porn
graphic positions to make them into like
like where I don't if you guys have seen
like the Greg land tracing issues that
have been going around but like gregl
can't draw any traces and Greg land also
will like when he has his like when he
has his women like did you just now
realize you were off camera this whole
time no I just I wanted to give her some
space okay if you if you look at Greg
land drawing women yelling he just
traces women having orgasms from really
yeah and this is a fun I'm learning a
lot about the way people draw stuff this
interesting yeah Google Greg land and
can't draw or sucks or like porn and you
will get Greg land and all the [__] he's
he's ripped off himself he's ripped off
porno pictures like it's just
insane can't draw that is actually a top
Google search for that the other funny
thing about that by the way is that the
other this is a variant cover the the
the the the Prime cover is by Greg
land is it yeah oh and it's not very
good but it's not very pornographic
either oh yeah if you if you look up
can't draw you'll see he takes like
Sports Illustrated and all that other
stuff
yep GRE Greg land I typed in Greg land
and then the next word that Google auto
completed was
tracing and there's literally just all
side by side pictures but even with L's
terrible art like he tries to like he
draws them with clothes on he draws them
doing
something action oriented this is a
naked woman painted pink like not even
red pink and she is and she has her and
and she's in a like an animalistically
submissive pose right I think that's
problem the issue well because spider
super spider woman has had one of the
big things with her is she's always been
super super skin tight I've seen a lot
of artwork from her in previous issues
where it's like you can see the belly
button indentation oh yeah yeah and like
and like you're almost like she's got to
be wearing underwear otherwise we' be
seeing a camel toe you know like it's
that's how tight it is and at the same
time it's the pose she's looking up at
you she's bent over down like that it's
it's not like you would not scale a
building like that even if you did have
spider no she's clearly at the top of
the building building and if you just
take the skyline out and put a guy
behind her we're going a whole different
direction at this point I didn't think
of it that way you just put very dirty
images of Spider Woman in my head well
all right all right so here's the thing
so let me be let me be a little more
dangerous here all right okay let me
walk a little bit
territory if that was a guy would you
say the same thing yeah oh yeah if I saw
a guy in that pose with the butt cheek
spread like that and okay not not
necessarily not necessarily like in that
same position CU that'd be I'd be like
okay like this is a little weird if it
was that position like no I'd be like
what I then I'd pick it up simply to be
like what the hell is happening yeah
what the hell going this but if it was a
guy why is a dude like that if it was a
guy like on the front cover of a comic
and it was accentuating like his male
features like if it was accentuating
like his penis would you I mean I'm I'm
saying like would you would you say the
same would you say like oh my God this
is ridiculous it's an over sexualized
thing I would say that it was overly
sexualized because I think that's
completely unnecessary to sell a comic
just like this is completely necessary
to sell a comic I mean every time they
put a guy on a cover who was wearing
something skin tight and they're showing
like muscles upon muscles that you
didn't even know existed that is sexual
them in the same manner as putting a
female in a a skin tight low cut you
know outfit you know it's it's very
similar so yeah if you did put like it
was just like junk I mean like yeah that
would really turn me off I'd be like
there's there's no reason for this this
is so going Beyond yeah I I think that
like we you try to imagine like a male
superhero in a sexually subservient or
even I would actually take more of an
issue with a ma with a male superhero
accentuated and being in a dominant pose
like in a domineering like position over
something else like over a woman or over
a character over like something like I
would be I would be put off it's also
just for me it's bad art like it's not
it's badly drawn and it's it's tasteless
this would be like like you were saying
Rob if you you were to to show off a
man's
junk like this would be like taking
Rocket Raccoon and having him pelvic
thrusting but cutting and pasting the
Hulk's dick on
him like that's how I feel I was just
looking for it and that's why cuz I was
looking for an example what of Rob said
but there's an image floating around and
I can't find it right now but it's a
genderbended version of if if Powergirl
was a guy how that costume would work
and what it is is they call it the [__]
window and it's a window right above
like the base of the penis oh so you get
a Little Neck yeah you get a little neck
but the it's still covered so we're okay
I was going to show that to be like
exact just a prime example of reversing
this on a guy right like I don't think I
would buy a guy with with a penis
window I but I also don't think I would
buy a guy with a penis window because it
that is similar but it isn't at the same
time I mean it's not like her boob
window is like you know a vagina window
you know what I mean it's not quite the
same thing like compar not G have like a
window guys just so shirtless at that
point so I just feel like it's it's also
drawn in a way so it's specifically
showing off her like it's specifically
drawn so that you could see her entire
ass yeah like like it's not drawn in a
way where she's like curved over and
she's kind of like crawling it's like
she's sticking it so far up in the air
just so you could see it well you know
how like they they like in back showing
it to the street below
yeah remember back in the 90s when like
artists would draw female characters and
they would they would have like no spine
so you could see both their ass and
their boobs yeah and they would like
twist it was like it was like the artist
hereen he was like okay she's going to
be facing the ground so we can't see her
boobs so we need to show as much of her
ass as possible to make up for the fact
we got to sell that ass that's exactly
it so it's an interesting point that she
is presenting her ass for us like that
is literally what she is doing she's put
herself in such a position yeah here's
the thing that she's like and here it is
if you if you you kept the same pose but
you turned it so that the all so that
the cover was of the was seeing this
pose from the other
side it would be
unfathomably offensive people people
especially with how tight her outfits
are yeah like and by the way I think
that that's actually a reaction to the
fact that because Spiderwoman is one of
the few female characters who wears
clothes from the like from her ears to
her toes that's their way of making up
for the fact that they can't show they
can't sexualize her like she's not
showing any leg leg she's not showing
off any butt there's no cleavage so we
have to do something and also I've
noticed over the years that like
superhero costumes are just let me draw
a human like in the Drone like you know
in their idealized form and then put a
costume on it like that's kind of how
they draw it like that's why you can see
their muscles through it it's why Batman
the movies have to have muscles actually
built into the suit like why would they
do that like why would Iron Man in the
90s have abs no no no the nipple armor
was the peak the nipple armor yeah yeah
because Batman can't have bat cha
nipples I think the way you fix this
image if you were going to is all he had
to do was clearly she's on it looks like
she's on one of those Ledges that you
know you'd be on a roof and you could
look over it yeah um is just to take the
camera and rotate it down so we're
looking up at her face yeah she was
looking down at us yeah doing the same
POS above
us freakish like triple jointed giraffe
neck well yeah like I said before like
when we first saw this like she looks
like the chick from The Grudge like
she's getting ready to like kill
somebody like that's that's what she
reminds me of but okay so I I love
playing Devils Advocate with people
which is why I love debating with people
about stuff but Tiffy I'm gonna ask you
one more question sure all right what if
I told you that the artist that Drew
this picture that that initially created
it said that he's doing her drawing her
in such a way to where she's presenting
the fact that she's comfortable with her
own sexuality and says that I'm okay
looking like this I mean couldn't an
argument be made to say that this is
this is a woman who's confident with her
sexuality okay and is it I see I see
you're look you know most women you see
on the street if if they can you know if
they have a good body or whatever
they're gonna probably want to show it
off usually it's because of based off of
a whole lot of work um and I don't mean
medical work I mean like physical work
like you went to the gym you you watch
what you eat that kind of thing you're
going to want to show off the work that
you've done and you're empowered by that
again that's fine if she if he wants to
put her in something so tight because
he's saying that that's because she is
you know confident confident who she is
and and you know you know strong you
know personality fine but I can tell you
right now someone like that wouldn't be
in a position like that they would not
pose themselves like that in such a
subservient way yeah she was confident
that like she wouldn't be on the
receiving end no and then she wouldn't
put herself in that kind of position
because nine times out of 10 a a strong
female will not do that like we're not
like why would I put myself in that kind
of position at all like if I want you to
see how like hot I look in something I'm
going to just show it to you but I'm not
going to like you know Crouch down and
be like hey what do you is that good you
like that
no it's not
happening I want to jump into this I'm
just going to say that's [__]
because that he would even claim that
because drawing that image you know what
people are going to take that as no I
guarantee you no one looked at that
image and went she is such a strong and
empowered female that she can can stick
her ass in my face get I get that much
but if anything art is interpretation
and I'm sure Tiffany can like AR can
tell me like that I'm 100% right here
like two people can look at the exact
same thing and see two different things
and so the the problem here is that you
have a circumstance where you have a I
mean all of us here can I think we can
all universally agree looking at that
picture that's clearly a character that
is designed to be displayed in a
sexualized and submissive position I
don't think there's any real debate here
on whether or not that's the case but
you could have somebody else who would
look at that and say that's not really
the case like she's just a woman who's
who's happy about her own sexuality
we've got a Litany of evidence given the
skin tight outfits that she wears and
all that kind of good stuff I mean you
can make a number of cases that way but
like I said I was just arguing for the
no I to I totally understand that and I
think that that is where that
generational Gap does come into play
because I guarantee you that artist
looks at that and he probably doesn't
have the same thought like he
understands he's like no she is sexy he
doesn't understand that he's gone too
far in the opposite direction I don't
even think he's trying intentionally to
yeah to to demean or degrade uh the
female form or the character he's like
no that's just how that's how I want
like that's how I see sexy yeah that's
it that's sexy and that's it there you
go I mean we've talked about this so
many times about how like when Sue storm
was created I mean her power was she
went away like like Sue's power like you
got oh a guy can catch on fire and a guy
can stretch we got a Rockman and we got
a woman who will go away like she just
fad weest power
ever and she has another if we can give
her two Powers one is she can go away in
other words she can shut up and then be
perfect she'll be the ideal woman for us
third power she can cook the most
incredible
meal bunch of sandwiches the likes of
which have never been rivaled by
any her cupcakes are the bomb of the
1950 fantastic War wow but again I know
that that comes from a generational Gap
and over time that character has changed
so I I think that part of the issue was
that this is coming from an older artist
who just doesn't understand how the
world is going to perceive his art you
know what and while I agree with you on
that because I think that's the
same I was gonna say I agree with you
because I think that's the same problem
we have with Adam Hughes I think Adam
Hughes does amazing art but some of his
characters are very much overly overly
done up and that's definitely because
Adam Hughes is like a six-year old guy I
like Adam hughes's uh pinup his like 50s
style like he's great with that oh yeah
abut and while I agree with you Tiffany
it's like you said at the very beginning
of this discussion how did the rest of
Marvel look at that and go yeah sell
that right that is what I cannot
comprehend yeah it's not even like this
guy is a veteran this isn't this isn't
Neil Adams doing them a cover this isn't
like Jack Kirby no one will question it
like oh it's Neil Adams whatever well no
I mean like but but it's not even like a
legend in the comics world who is come
who is like coming off of it's not like
it's not like Stan Lee who if he could
draw like was like I'll draw you guys a
cover and it was this I mean people
would have a huge problem with it and
he'd be accountable for it but even then
like that would be a reason for Marvel
to go let's give it a pass and let's put
it out but like this guy is like we got
this Italian painter to do this cover
for us thanks well I can I can tell you
exactly why I passed at Marvel because
of this portion of the podcast because
people would sit around and say oh my
God what was Marvel like it would be it'
be free publicity but that was that was
the whole reason why I asked that
question in the first place or those
series of questions because like a
couple years ago I took like a semester
of gender studies but nonetheless like
like we were talking about like
advertising like women in advertising
and if you look at like a lot of
different advertisements in terms of
like selling a product to men or even to
women like you have women in these
positions where they're either like
submissive or you might have a woman
like half her bodies in the trunk
indicating that she was killed or
something like that like you have all
these different kinds of advertisements
that are played out in such a way to
where it looks like for some reason like
women are somehow being uh like
subjected you know or being I guess
maybe like used in in some kind of a
negative fashion but at the end of the
day like people still buy the product
and so the question is you know what
what would motivate somebody to create a
or to create like an advertisement that
way and it's just based on the simple
fact that it sells like it just I was
say it SS to pretty much wrap up most of
this conversation here um I did just go
to my comic book store and said when the
new Spiderwoman comes out put that on my
list my pull list in that variant cover
I want a copy of
it you know my thinking as a collector
is this is making headlines probably GNA
be worth something and it's probably a
$10 variant yeah I me but in all honesty
I just went there and put it aside just
so if the negativity gets to V vitriol
or get gets to vitriolic Marvel will
pull it yeah yeah and then it'll be even
rarer yes but they they'll wait until
the last minute to do that yes I mean
partovy doesn't honestly think that any
of this was originally planned no and I
think now that it's happing they're like
okay let's this take this and let's run
with it I me it's kind of like what
happened with the deadpol trailer leak
that that wasn't planned at all but then
they spun it into a well we might be
able to do this and here's the HD
version relase yeah yeah I mean yeah
pretty much said it all I mean like when
it comes down to it like you know we all
agree that sex cells and and it's are
you GNA buy the cover I think am I gonna
buy that cover are you gonna buy that
cover no CU I book I me like no not even
because it's like gratuitous because
again like I read Saga and I love every
image in that book regardless of what it
is I love it and it fits with the story
and it makes sense and it's done for a
reason I think this is bad art and I
don't want to own bad art yeah and
that's literally what it comes down to
Art sucks and I don't want none of that
[__] I read Saga too and I agree with
you I like the way Saga portrays it and
I I read a lot of the Indie books now
cuz that's what we've been doing over at
the channel and a lot of them do it in a
a tasteful way I don't feel like I'm
reading porn and then there's some of
them that I'm like I'm reading porn this
is you're like no you're just doing this
to get a rise you're just doing this
because you think it's edgy not because
it has anything to do necessar story or
building a world yeah by the way that
image of Spider Woman reminds me of
something I would see at a con like some
no names booth and I'd walk by and be
like what the hell is no it'll have like
a $200 price tag and he'll have sold
like 900 of of them that day
yeah but yes so um so I guess we can all
just agree that this definitely could
have been a better designed image but
that Marvel is using the publicity of it
to just be like hey even if you don't
buy this like buy something so
train okay so
well if you moving on to the next topic
do you want me to move on I was gonna
say we can move on to the next all right
next topic then is so we've discussed
the axis event that's coming up and
we've discussed the reaction to the
Marvel Spider Woman thing so now we're
going to flip switch and go over to DC
now DC is ending this month by ending
every single one of their books any
books that ended last month they're
getting an extra issue just to get an
extra story Batman's got one about
Batman just catching a random villain
awesome oh I loved it it was great one
of the best Batman books read in it's
literally one of the best Batman books
written in the last 10 years it's just a
single Batman shot about Batman
literally stating this is going on this
is going on this is going on but I still
need to prove to Gotham I catch the G I
still got work to do it's just pure
Batman you didn't even need him
acknowledging it it was just you could
read that book 20 years from now 20
years ago it would be it would be a
solid comic no question about it it was
a great it was gun in one which I never
get oh yeah they never do that anymore
you never get to buy one book but a lot
of a lot of comics are doing that right
now because um as a matter of fact uh
but as actually so is Marvel right now
because it's setting up for axis all new
uh X-Men just did one of those one shots
but uh what's going on now is we're
setting up for this event right here
this has been going on weekly for three
months now yeah now a little bit of
history as to what's going on here I
explained it a little to Rob I explained
it a little to David already but what
Marvel DC has done is in May for the
free comic book day we had a situation
where we had Futures in Futures Zen was
10 years in the future um and DC has
lost to brother's eye brother's eye is a
like giant robot thing and basically
turns everyone into these half robots
that brother eye can control even
Superman was taken down by brother's eye
yeah somehow all right okay they never
explain how but we lost Superman I have
no idea what the hell's going on here I
don't read DC
so giant robot absorbs Superman now
Batman being the only guy remaining and
O of course always an old man at this
point um and Batman Beyond Terry
mcginness said we need to fix this we're
going to Batman himself was going to go
back in time to before brother ey was
even invented and prevent it from
happening at the last second they get
attacked and Terry mcginness has to go
back in time and he wasn't able to
stabilize where where he's going and
what he does is he ends up 5 Years From
current New 52 story lines so he's 5
years in the future now for the last
three months we've been playing this
stupid game of letting all of our big
heroes are gone Batman's missing
Superman is wearing a mask and we're
questioning if it's really him uh Wonder
Woman pops up like I think she popped up
randomly maybe not um like every
everybody's missing we don't know what
happened and you're we've been slowly
establishing that there was a war with
Earth 2 um and we won what there was a
lot of damage and a lot of things
happened during that we don't fully know
what's going on all of the earth two
people have been captured and put into
these cells and uh We've now been with
this book I hate it because it doesn't
really establish anything that's going
on it just keeps filling in filler with
crap characters no one cares about it's
following grifter and uh like hold on
grifter it's like grifter um
Frankenstein amethyst everybody who
failed in a solo book yep ended up in
Futures End
what a great way to sell Comics I know
here here's an image character and a
Timeless monster and this oh my God I
just saw this here's the checklist for
September oh wow that looks like secret
Invasion man here's years worth of [__]
that you need to follow on that's funny
because my secret Invasion list was uh
seven books it was secret Invasion 1
through 7 and it was great dude the tie
it's it's like a year let me finish off
6 we'll go on over these signs in a
minute but so okay so basically Terry
mcginness came back it's 5 years in the
future brother I has been started but he
isn't at the point he's ass so Terry
mcginness is been trying to stop it but
at the same time we're recovering from a
war with Earth 2 um there is a massive
threat coming to face off at the world
and we don't fully know what's going on
right now um they left a lot of
questions that was almost like watching
Lost you don't know but there's a lot of
questions going on yeah and next month
every book in dcns and they all jump
five years to meet with this timeline
and start a addressing these questions
yeah that we've now been posing for the
last three months with this okay um now
this is now let me read this this
checklist for you guys real quick this
is what's coming out in September only
in September okay you if you want to
follow this event you need to pick up
Action Comics one Aquaman one Aquaman
and the others one Batgirl one Batman
one Batman and Robin one Batman and
Superman one batwing Batwoman birds of
pre these are all number ones they're
all started over with Futures and number
one um Booster Gold Catwoman Constantine
Detective Comics Earth 2 Grayson Green
Arrow Green Lantern Green Lantern core
Green Lantern new Guardians Harley Quinn
Infinity men and the forever people
that's a totally new
book Justice League Futures End justice
league dark Futures End Justice League
United Futures End new Suicide Squad Red
Hood and the Outlaws Red Lantern
Sinestro Spar Star Spangled War Stories
that's a new one they got they got rid
of that book uh Super Boy super girl
Superman Superman and Wonder Woman SW
thing Teen Titans the flash Trinity of
the sin Pandora Trinity of sin Phantom
Wonder Woman Futures End world's finest
super Futures End um every single one of
them has a variant cover so my question
for the general comic book reading
public who the [__] is going to
read com most likely most likely you
just still need to follow the stories
that you want to follow but I guarantee
you just like when the new 52 launched
there's going to be tidbits as to what's
going on in the rest of the books in the
series and to really understand it you
need to buy every freaking book that
comes out so just just to give you guys
an idea oh wait wait hold on all for a
time Jump five years in the future
they're gonna undo that what what
they're claiming right now is that this
is may or may because this also ties
into multiversity yeah that this may or
may not cause another crisis in the DC
Universe yep which will then
retroactively get rid of all of this and
bring back the original DC Universe so
great hang can ask you guys something as
comic book readers does it annoy you or
annoy the hell out of you that for some
reason DC tends to try to constantly
focus on new readers as opposed to the
people who they already have because it
seems like right now if they're going to
be restarting at number one so they're
trying to cater to someone like me who
hasn't jumped on to anything because
they're like hey come on in right now
it's a number one you want to get in at
a number one because then you can just
follow it from there instead of having
people who are long running fans who are
like I just want to have a story that
makes sense and I can follow yes that
that is why exactly why I can't get into
DC's
continuity D exactly why no I'm sorry
that's why I love Marvel no Marvel does
it to a degree but not the same degree
like Cameron was asking me earlier he
was like I've been reading Marvel Now
like what's a good place to start
because the problem that he has is like
he was reading Deadpool and he's reading
like various other characters all right
the good thing about Marvel is Marvel
focuses on new readers and the old
readers like uh what what I was talking
about earlier Richard Ryder I said
Richard Ryder is going to come back you
know he he might be a good guy might be
a bad guy whatever but it'll be Marvel
Now Richard Ryder issue number one and
then then you'll just kind of start off
with this new version of Richard Ryder
but it also caters to the old fans
because the old fans know the history of
Richard Ryder and the old fans want
Richard Ryder to come back as Nova and
so you have this element where you have
Marvel tying into the old stuff and
tying into the new stuff and they're
bringing in the interests of people on
both sides side so T can sit down and
say okay like who the hell is Richard
Ryder why do people love him and she can
just read Richard Ryder number one and
say okay he's Nova he was in the cancer
verse you know whatever and she can pick
it up and know what's going on and then
s can be like okay Richard Ryder was the
first Nova he's the best one done and
done and that's it and people I actually
agree with you that because I just did
those videos Mar what is Marvel Now what
is the new 52 and I I like Marvel now's
mentality better cuz they do a whole
bunch of new number ones now this is
very similar to the to the Marvel Now
system um because what it is is they're
giving you a new number one they're
giving you the new reader a jumping off
point Tiffany but at the same time in
Marvel Now All That Old history is still
valid so if you are an oldtime reader
you'll understand more of the inside
jokes and all that stuff that's going on
um the first time New 52 happened they
did this and they erased everything so
you had to be a new reader even if you
were an old reader yeah this one is
jumping five years in the future so all
of our old history with these old books
is still good but my concern is going
five years in the future is any of the
old stories going to matter Superman
being doomsday is that going to
matter it'll have happened like I think
they're going to keep they're going to
keep the continuity that has been
happening for three
years right but I I mean like if you're
G to Jump Ahead five years and you're
gonna age your characters five years
older than they were when you rebooted
the universe at New
52 it means you have to go back five
years ago go again like at the end of it
which means that whatever is happening
in this current timeline 5 years from
now will be undone which means that this
story is irrelevant yes well what I
think they're doing honestly is one of
the coolest things about the New 52 and
and what drove a lot of sales was the
question of what happened because we
started we did Justice League saw how
the whole team came together and then we
jumped five years then yeah and then and
then we had series like zero year we had
uh the zero issues explaining how a lot
of guys got their powers we had a whole
bunch of mysteries that we were able to
go back and resolve and go back to and I
think what DC's run into now is they've
answered all of those and they're like
well what do we do now oh let's go five
more years and then we have five more
years of backstory to do better with
yeah and that's that's the thing oh like
the big the biggest question right now
the biggest question is who is this
guy this Captain is is the guy's posing
as Superman but he acts more Brash he's
more uh to the point and he's wearing a
mask now the debate is is that Superman
who's been affected by the war or is
that somebody else and if it's somebody
else that means Superman is also missing
along with Batman um Green Arrow has
been killed that one blows my mind that
we've killed green arrow in in the
future's end event well they've killed
him twice already so I mean it's another
time but um all right so so one thing uh
people in the chat love you
Tiffany people people in the chat think
you're awesome but one of the one of the
really cool things Tiffany can you come
back and S just take a few weeks
off I mean I think we should have
Tiffany on the podcast more still
represents TV little house what are you
worried
about you're a better face of the
company than I am um but this is this is
one of the funny things because like I
said you know marvel does a better job I
think tying into the old stuff while
keeping the new stuff like for example
during Avengers versus X-men there's a
point where Iron Man is talking to
Captain America you know like are you
sure you're doing the right thing like
basically facing off against the X-Men
and Captain America says yes like I'm
trying to save the world and Iron Man
says it wasn't too long ago go I was on
the opposite side and you were fighting
against me it's the hom of Civil War the
Civil War is pre Marvel now so it's like
okay it still happened exactly it's if
you're a new reader and you read that
you just go oh what happened yeah and
then you go back Civil War was sick man
yeah exactly and so why Surfers the I I
can only think of one time that Marvel
legitimately tried to New 52 their stuff
and they didn't reboot the univer well
okay uh heroes are born but let's not
talk about that yes oh no let's talk
about heroes re born I love heroes so
terrible but like that was more or less
like their Ultimate Universe but like
was that what ultimate is yeah yeah yeah
it's basically the Ultimate Universe
they took like they got Rob lield and
Jim Le to draw Marvel all over again
with no Spider-Man but when Spider-Man's
clone came back or when when they killed
the Clone and Spider-Man became
reinstated they did a book called
chapter one where they just said you
know what let's just get John burn to
retcon a whole bunch of stuff from
Spider-Man's past so like Spider-Man
getting it bit by the spider instead of
the spider getting like hit by radiation
and it bit him and then he goes home
there's a lab explosion and the spider
gets irradiated and Dr Octopus was there
and he got his arms grafted to his body
and like because Sandman and Norman
Osborne have very similar drawn hair
from the 60s now they're related and Dr
Doom had a very similar technology to
the chameleon in Amazing Spider-Man 1
and four so let's have the chameleon
actually be lad Varian and he works for
Dr Doom like let's connect all this crap
and John bam will write it and draw it
and nobody liked it and what they did
was at the and at the end they were like
listen this is this is what happened
like this is now Spider-Man's history
and the readers just said no it's not
and then and then the next like and then
when they re when they because they did
chapter one and it was like a miniseries
and they came back to Amazing Spider-Man
and web of Spider-Man and everything
else and when they came back they just
said yeah that didn't happen nah never
mind like they tried to new 50 they
tried to relaunch it and they were also
doing that as a way to make Peter Parker
younger like that was their way to kind
of like they they always try to reset
him to be younger that's like yeah which
is like [__] because it never he's
relatable as a kid never let him age
yeah no trust me when I was n he was
married and he was still awesome so
whatever but like the fact is that
chapter one thing was like I think the
only time that Marvel dip their toe in a
crisis type water and they and the the
the backlash was so severe they were
like let's just not even try that again
like that's the only time I remember
them actually trying to say like no the
stuff you remember that didn't happen at
all yeah well have you guys been reading
the rumor mill the supposedly the
incursions the Age of Ultron Wolverine
snap and everything all of this is event
in axis is all leading to a Marvel
crisis type event to reset everything
yes i' heard well I heard that like my
guess is if they do anything which they
might not because it's Marvel we don't
know they might take the Multiverse or
all the different dimensions reduce them
to one and push everything into one like
amalgam so like everyone's young but
everything happen like so it's more like
it's more of a soft reboot than an
actual res what Marvel Now technically
was it was just technically a soft
reboot well even then like it's not like
I hate that because it's not it's they
didn't reboot anything they just
renumbered the books and started over
like they just did what they're supposed
to do every couple of years which was
clean up the clean up the story a little
and they don't have to clean up the
continuity everything's can still happen
they just need to make the story less
complicated to this time around so
Spider-Man can fight Venom this time he
doesn't have to fight like his life
model decoy monster versions of his
parents who were actually a byproduct of
the Harry Osborne Green Goblin who is a
puppet from the chameleon like we don't
need that story we just need a story
where Spider-Man fights the Venom and
it's cool like all that stuff still
happened but let's let's let let's take
it easy on our readers for a year that's
what Marvel's really good at doing those
kind of stories though like Siege like
Siege like there was no Hidden Hand it
was just like you know Osborne and Loki
like let's just invade Asgard and just
take that [__] over like that's
basically what happened and then like
you know Loki ends up killed or whatever
it is like he ends up getting destroyed
by centy and was it was it that or was
it dark rain I can't remember which one
where dark rain took place right dark
rain led up to okay and it was
great it went secret Invasion dark rain
Siege you might even say that forever
evil was inspired by it no
oh but nonetheless like don't you don't
you tread on my skin yo y get get off of
my DC so when did the2 reboot 11 2011
2011 so three years later they're re it
was rebooting when I was coming home
from Afghanistan and I was like oh this
going to be so cool start playing Comics
again yeah now now DC is just gonna be
renumbering but with a time Jump yep
right right well because me with the
new2 I used to just read trades like
forever I would wait for the whole thing
to finish put trades cuz I didn't I I
didn't know where to jump in and that's
where a lot of comic creers have like
you can't jump mid story arc you know so
I just wait for the trade to come out
and read the trade then if it do happen
and for me that was when I got back to
buying weekly books because I was like I
know I know where it is yeah and that's
and that's that Tiffany is what like
what Marvel did like Marvel Marvel got
to this point in their continuity where
they said like something had to change
and that's what happened with the house
of him you had this this series whereby
there were just so many mutants in the
Marvel Universe they just couldn't keep
track of them all like there were saw
mutants that pop up and then you just
never saw or heard from them because
there was just no point in them being
there m that showed up and made force
fields there was actually one guy he
appeared I think in the 1960s maybe the
1970s I can't remember his name but Jean
Gray forced him to make a force field
around himself and he suffocated inside
of it like there were just yeah there
were just goofy characters that would
pop up so Marvel came along and Marvel
said okay House of M comes to an end no
House of are
gone did a hold on man let me let me
explain this man my god dude so anyway
so Marvel reboots everything they or
they lead to that point but they
basically eliminate all the mutants all
right that was step one all right then
you had Civil War where you had this
whole con this whole conflict take place
between superheroes that were not
mutants mutants were out of the way at
this point and so it was simply like
dividing the lines and there was just a
really cool storyline then you had
secret Invasion and secret invasion was
Marvel sort of rounting everything that
happened with Civil War it was whole
population almost all the entire Earth
was replaced with Scrolls and then the
actual superheroes and normal people
came back
and then Marvel came along and they said
okay now we're restarting everything
like everything's going to be totally
revamped Marvel now and Marvel Now is
Marvel's version of The New 52 from DC
where you have like all these Number One
issues of all these characters so you
have like Magneto number one and you
have all these new backstories and stuff
and that's where the whole thing that
Benny was talking about coming from
where you have like uh the all new X-Men
and you have the X-Men of the Past
coming into the future into the present
and all that kind of good stuff taking
place yeah I I I I think you're giving
Marvel too much credit I I like Marvel I
do hold on hold on I like Marvel I do
but you can see if you look at the
marketing standpoint in the direct
correlation to sales versus decis
decisions Marvel and DC came out with
new 52 Marvel had no plans for reboots
no Marvel now no nothing DC came out new
52 and that was the biggest comic sales
month like in 10 years it was huge and
immediately following that Marvel did
X-Men versus The Avengers which resolved
in tons of new number ones they didn't
reboot this the the universe but they
rebooted all their books uncanny
Avengers and stuff like that I I know I
know you want to say House of M LED in
it was purpose House of M definitely was
to clean up the mutants everything from
House of M to Avenger versus X-Men was
just Bendis having fun with no that's
not true dud they not look at the sales
you have to look at the sales report I
disagree DC had sold DC beat Marvel in
like the sales in that one month alone
beat Marvel over the last like three
years and DC would forget it they almost
didn't exist at that point like that's
why immediately following that we had
Avengers versus X-Men new number ones
within a year no not directly correlate
with story quality
though like I I mean I'll agree with you
the house event was to clean up the
mutants because that was a horrendous
problem we had like 4,000 [__]
mutants that was Joe cada he was like he
he was like they have their own Island
like they have their own burrow in New
York we need to put a lid on this uh
they had their own Island and then cand
cand NOA killed them all so I don't know
if you you guys noticed but I Linked In
in the Skype call uh a character called
gold
balls gold balls and his power is to
create rubber balls out of his
skin wow and he's in
123 isues Som I'm not I'm not saying
that Marvel didn't sit down immediately
follow new52 and go holy crap look at
how many Comics sold and we're Marvel
you can't you can't beat Marvel what
should we do oh let's do Avengers versus
X-men everyone gets mad the X-Men blame
the Avengers for not ever backing them
during the House of M event and all that
stuff well we'll retroactively say all
of this needs to be corrected and then
we'll just do new number ones and then
the Marvel Now was an experiment I don't
know if you're tracking that one either
if you look into the history of it it
was an experiment with phases on purpose
because what happened was Marvel now
came out and their sales blew New 52 out
of the water cuz that was a year after
New 52 launched and all of us readers
were like what the fudge is this this
doesn't make any you you've made things
worse yeah and so Marvel Now outsold
them so new 52 then said here's phase
two we're shutting down some books and
bringing more and Marvel Now was like
here's phase two and then Marvel Now was
like we're kicking your ass three four
five nine phases let's just do
yeah oh yeah do you think any of the
Marvel Now success also has to do with
the success that Marvel has had with
their movies because I know that that
must bring at least a small percentage
of people in just wondering what am I
missing out on it I think what they did
was because because if you look at the
the history in the sales um Marvel uh DC
new52 came out Marvel now came out and
what Marvel Now initially was was
reinventions of teams new writing team
stuff like that it wasn't what it is now
Marvel Now originally was like uncanny
Avengers all new X-Men stuff you hadn't
expected on the following waves it then
turned into Magneto number one cyclop
Hwy number one and they were and I think
that was from the reaction to the movies
of people like having a character they
can enjoy and having a starting for that
character and I've actually spoke with
the comic book guys at the store to see
how this has been panning out and they
State like the the way Marvel sends it
to sends it to them how they're going to
do this they only tell them that there's
a Planned eight issues to 12 issues
expected to end within that unless they
are next big thing yeah well I guess
that would make sense because I'm sure
your general public may not have the uh
stamina to keep buying a series over
years and years as opposed to they might
just enjoy a yeah mini series
essentially and then if they end up
becoming a comic book fan there's so
many other titles they may choose from
then yeah and that's that's that's the
whole the whole conflict behind it
because you have characters like like
Marvel's really hyping up Paul Rudd and
the new Ant-Man movie buttman's Never
had a solo series like never except for
Eric
Grady okay I don't count that that's
like what the 20 issues it's I no okay
there's so many characters that have
okay you know what happens when a
character has 20 issues it means their
[__] got canceled because nobody wanted
to buy their yeah it got
canel and it was a serious book I I
count I count a serious solo issue when
we're getting into like a hundred issues
like that's when I say okay this that's
not gonna happen ever anymore I know I
know but I'm saying like the um but but
you well Marvel now you know what doing
when that happens right a great a great
test case of what they're doing right
now Gambit we know Gambit's popular
right yeah Gambit got a solo book I
don't think it went past six issues no
so instead instead of canceling Gambit
they're like Gambit now leads X
Force I mean it's it's a smart it's a
smart move to make yeah but you know
that but that's that's the thing you
know like I mean Ant-Man has his has his
big moments but Ant-Man was an Avenger
he was always an Avenger he was part of
the Avengers team and he just I mean the
two biggest stories involving Ant-Man
Hank Pim as far as I'm concerned are
like the original uh instance where he
created Ultron I guess you could you
could consider the one where Ultron like
hypnotized him whatever to where he made
jasta and then you could talk about um
the uh Age of Ultron where Wolverine
breaks time goes back in time kills Hank
Pim and then does it again to stop
himself from doing it so you know those
are like some of the biggest stories
involving uh Hank Pim Antman and then
Scott Lang I mean he was okay but hell
man he got killed so
yeah Children's Crusade as a Layman the
only things I know about Ant-Man is that
he can get small and communicate with
insects he created Ultron and he hit his
wife that is what I know about pretty
much the only significant things in his
history unless Jack a wife beater that's
what everybody says like beats his wife
but but even in the comics he's still a
wife beater in age of ulton they're like
oh you know they're like oh by the way
you're going to make Ultron and he's
going to kill everyone he's going to
rule the world so don't do that and
we're going to lose it's going to be
horrible oh and don't beat your wife
yeah don't beat your wife yeah I don't
your wife it's just not it's he really
regrets it but well I'm Yellow Jack it's
not like take it back he feels real bad
about it they got back together a couple
times since then so like you
know they got they got they've actually
reconciled at least two other times
since he hit her and never during their
relationship or afterwards did he ha her
again
so he learned his
and he he did uh in in the mighty
Avengers dark rain book uh really have a
scene with jaka who's like some weird
like
Android supposed to be the M of
Ultron it was I like how DA's trying to
put this whole thing together as we're
go he's like there's a wasp and her mind
was stolen P the pH gentlemen there was
Ant-Man and yellow jacket at the same
time I don't know how that works and but
he he he had a scene where where she she
was asking about like why he he would
hit her and and he just said well I
didn't really think about it it was just
something I did in the moment and I've
regretted it ever since and I'm so sorry
and I wish I could tell her that I'm
sorry but she's dead now yeah and and
because she like exploded in the the
secret Invasion like final battle Yeah
well you know what's funny about it
though is Marvel likes to ground their
characters in realism but they always
give them these like one defining trait
of oh that was their that was their
moment that was the thing they did and H
course Iron Man has that every like six
minutes I was goingon to say Iron Man
Iron Man's got the alcoholism and the
whole Iron Man versus Hulk thing it was
that that was the reason why he made the
Hulk oh he was drinking that 50-year-old
bottle they made they made a point to
say it was a 50-year-old bottle of
Scotch like do we need didn't know at
this point that Iron Man's rich like
yeah well I'm just I'm drinking a full
bottle of Johnny Walker Blue because you
know I'm rich I know like do you need to
establish he has money
like like they showed his payment it was
Tony Stark for one hour of work $500,000
in a 50-year-old bottle of Scotch I'm
like you what yeah I mean that's that's
the kicker when it comes to characters
like even now like Wolverine still
brings up Jean Gray like like during a
vintage versus X you know he was talking
to Hope Summers Phoenix force and he was
like the Phoenix took someone from me
that I love it's like it's been like 30
years man
dude the new Wolverine movie he's coping
with killing Jean Gray and the whole
time of the movie I'm like cool man he's
coping with it but then that freaking
thing happened like seven years ago
movie time which is like 29 years real
world like yeah you're acting like this
was yesterday yeah yeah I mean it's not
like it happened like like a week and a
half ago like it's been a while man like
I understand it takes this whole but but
it's time to move on exactly you killed
the woman you love oh well your
Wolverine but uh but yeah it's it's it's
weird to me all right so we're running I
think we're actually running pretty
close um three hours three hours we all
ran our hour our hours beforehand we're
good well I mean we've only been
streaming for two hours so remember we
do whatever we got three
more it falls apart doesn't it after a
couple hours uh I mean we're not I'm not
showing any problem the quality does to
a certain extent but if we're not seeing
it yet then it's just yeah there's no
predetermined time at this point it's
going to fall apart I mean I'm watching
like I'm watching The Stream at the
moment so and still no one has explain
to me the first eight pages that I read
of that of Co of multi of Multiplicity
multiversity multiplicity talking about
M ke
mov okay what happens is Michael Keaton
duplicates himself and then the movie
just goes downhill from well you see
Kevin Bacon wanders into town oh God
Kevin Bacon hold on I can actually
explain this because they they did an
interview with Grant Morrison about this
explaining what the what the opening is
um the multiversity the storyline for
this and S let me see if I can if I can
explain to you why DC gets crazy with
this crap okay the multiversity is is
comic books that's what it is that's
what he's explained um in the comic
characters are reading the comic of
multiversity or like I think for issue
one's like they're reading Ultram man or
something like that and in that comic
like in this one the main character is
reading Ultra Comics U whole part of the
multiversity thing what is this and so
it's like it's like a meta thing like
he's in there reading the comic you're
reading and the comic that he's reading
is Earth seven which is this one so like
it's it's like layered on top of itself
kind of a thing right and I got like I
read I went to um one of the sites that
had the first eight pages up as the
preview and I and I read through it and
I thought to myself I would never buy
this based on these first aid p
I was like I feel like you're being
intentionally confusing just because you
think that that is good writing that's
Grant Morrison oh God like if you if you
think that's difficult like here's a
challenge for you if you think that's
tough here's a challenge a symbol for me
the chronological reading order of the
Age of Apocalypse like tell me in what
order I should read all those coms like
that is challenge that's why we don't do
age of apoc that's why we don't do agage
apocalypse Marvel Marvel came along and
said here's like 110 issues like see if
you can sort it out
[__] like 11 volumes of Trades like yeah
eat me I just I want to say one thing
and I can see why you were confused
because if I didn't explain that to you
right now multiversity opens with one
guy reading the comic yep then it jumps
to a pirate monkey
yep then it jumps to Nick uton which is
basically our Watcher yep saying that
he's the super judge then then the
monkey Nicks uton and what appears to be
I don't even I don't know black Superman
I don't know what that is black Superman
are now fighting that could be Obama
Superman what apparently looks like
schuma Gora from Marvel schora it's a
giant eye monster it's the one between
the dimensions maybe it's maybe it's
their version of staro so just to give
you guys an idea I know you mentioned
Rob Age of Apocalypse
Age of Apocalypse was a Year's worth of
comics right and they were very good yes
yes and they were they were very good
but the the whole collection between the
full Omnibus which is about 1,200 pages
and the companion which is the books
obviously surrounding what goes on in
the Omnibus that's like 700 right mhm so
that's 1,800 Pages the Futures End
Omnibus which is a couple months of
comics at most is
9 12
Pages wait what that's
yeah that's what you were saying with
all of the books that you have to
collect to follow the event oh oh you're
talking about the whole collection I
thought you were talking about this
piece of crap I'm like I'm not buying
that many issues no but the the entire
collection is almost a thousand pages
and it comes out in December so it's
probably ending sometime early in
November so they have time to print it
no no honestly I think I think it's a
one to two months I think I think it's
literally supposed to happen in
September and
October oh no no no no I know what
you're looking at um okay every
September DC does a anniversary deal
where every book matches up for one
month that's what that is why they're
doing them all but normally the matchup
is like oh this is just the origins of
all the characters oh this is the new
reboot this looks like you need to buy
all the issues to know what the fudge is
going on that's
yeah well if this is a collection of all
those books like this isn't like the oh
like this is all of the books like
printed in order this is this is the
story for Futures End yeah yeah and it's
p what that's going to be because if you
look at it you can get uh issue zeros
you can also get the initial launch of
the new 52 which is all 52 issues issue
ones um and that's probably just going
to be the issue ones the future end
because Future's end is from what we've
been told supposed to resolve closer to
March and April where it's going to this
is where the rumors come out of collide
with the original
Universe yeah so this is an event that's
going to go on for the next like six
months and I'm probably G to get to the
end of it and not care and at the end of
it be like thank God we're back to
normal that's kind of like what happened
with me in the Batman zeroy year like
two and a half year story that Scott
Snider was writing I eventually got to
the point where I'm just like dude can
we just end this crap and get me back to
modern day Batman he was really spinning
his wheels towards the last four months
yeah yeah like dude really how long of a
story are you going to write about a
time displac basically Batman because
he's totally not matching with anything
at this point well no it's a it was a
prequel we're just I'm going to tell you
of rcon I'm gon to I'm going to redcon
in that Riddler was Batman one of
Batman's first villains and there you go
but um but no Dave like I get the point
that you're making like I'm I'm I'm not
saying that Comics are not bigger now
than they used to be like they certain
like there's certainly more comics in a
shorter amount of time now than they
used to be but what I'm saying like now
at least it's ordered like at least you
get like a table of com that's true but
then it was just like here's a [__] ton
of comics and hopefully you can figure
it out but if you can't well then you
better go online and find a read order
oh yeah no no you were 100% right Rob if
you want to get a great example this is
what turned me off of comics back in the
90s clone saga Spider-Man when he had
like six running series y that that was
the wor even try like I don't even I
don't even I don't even try to read that
like I I told I told uh s like I was
screwing around the other day when you
guys were live streaming I was like
dudee maximum security maximum security
was awful that was it was a terrible
series dude I'm telling
youself Deadpool core Deadpool core
don't like
Deadpool I'm gonna keep pushing it all
right so this is like me this is like me
and the all new Xmen am I the only one
who reads Deadpool also I mean I need to
get caught up on all new X-Men if it if
it seems that good but no all new X-Men
is incredible I mean stories are
definitely the stories have definitely
gotten better I mean maximum security
was Ron and the yuzer showing up on the
earth and he was like the Earth is now a
prison planet it's like okay like this
is stupid I mean that was basically The
Story So yeah so I mean like stories
have definitely gotten better but if all
new X-Men is as good as you say then
I'll definitely have to get caught up on
it yeah it's fun I mean it's written by
Bendis and it's got great art God Bendis
man that guy does not write bad stories
no no Bend Bendis and he knows and he
knows how to wrap his stories up well he
doesn't just leave them all hanging and
funky tangents and stuff yeah Grant
Morrison somebody said that in the chat
like when you were talking about like
all the craziness going on somebody was
like it's just Morrison being Morrison
yeah right dud okay okay BR Morrison has
written some great stuff when you have
him on Rails when you say Grant Morrison
write me the Arkham Asylum origin we get
a mosaic picture of Batman in the
background and some guy wearing a
woman's dress when you go gr Morrison
can you do another CR
you just blew no dude the number one
most requested video on my channel until
I did it was Final crisis because no one
I couldn't follow it I had to call S and
sort out my notes he said I said here
for four months doing that script and it
took me calling s going okay I got notes
what the heck is this yeah Benny Vinny's
not lying either guys like we would get
on and like we would just have random
conversations like what are you doing
he's like I'm still trying to figure out
final crisis it's been three and a half
months man it's like the problem with
final crisis wasn't even so much that it
that the core story itself was was was
difficult it was how do I cliffnote this
and what can I take out yeah yeah sounds
like gret Morrison needs like a little
sandbox Universe just for him him I
think he's made one it's called the Wii
three it's about a bunch of animals who
have been experimented on and our crazy
like awesome superheroes which by the
way he also claims is in his weapon plus
project which is he invented the weapon
plus project for Weapon X so weapons
three and five are the we three animals
but since they belong to vertigo and not
Marvel uh he just says oh it's
experimented on animals in my universe
what bet you didn't know that one I'm
actually amazed that you went in depth
as you did with like the Weapon X
Project I'm like did did Penny just
really like explain all the weapon
X's
really like Weapon X Wolverine thanks
for watching guys peace
yeah I almost did that for Groot when I
did the Groot explanation video I was
going to do two of them and I was going
to put them out one right after another
like Tuesday would be Groot and then
other day two would be the real Groot
but the first one I was going to do was
going to be 10 seconds of me going
welcome to Groot know your Universe I am
Groot and then I was going to end the
video and just upload it I mean that's
that's what I did with the one above all
like I was trying to make that video and
then I like I finished it and I got on
that's why I told Dave like like I just
did a video about the one above all
that's like 177 minutes long he appears
in 17 Comics I don't know how I managed
to do this yeah but I did and hopefully
it's not going to suck so let see what
happens you're 100% right Kenji the last
issue of final crisis you went from
planet Earth to space to flashing
forward to people telling the story the
whole concept behind final crisis is
Grant Morrison has this like notion that
superheroes are the modern-day like
Greek gods and Vikings and there are are
big story tellers so final crisis was
his way of showing that in the future
they're telling the story of final
crisis to the children but it was being
told by the superheroes who lived in the
adventure okay up until you got to that
part I was on board that sounded pretty
cool I I like mythology I was like that
sounds neat until that end part in which
you don't want to get into final running
Theory and idea his running Theory and
idea is that we this is the modern day
Gods the modern day mythics That's How
come every time Grant Morrison writes DC
Superheroes they are literally Gods on
earth like that that is how they get
portrayed um and final crisis he just
went off the wall he lost me when he
made Superman sing Dark Side to
death what yeah dark dark side shows up
and we find out that dark side hates
music so Superman to defeat Dark Side
sings at the exact Pitch Perfect note
because he's a god of course the exact
Pitch Perfect note that destroys dark
side's physical body yeah I mean it's
it's interesting it's interesting the
way they do that stuff like like we'll
get into this guys when we talk about um
Infinity Gauntlet but people are like
I'm wonder where like all the gods that
exist in the real world where they rank
in the hierarchy and like the Marvel
Universe like they're all Sky fathers
guys they're not that
powerful yeah stuff but they all hang
out with Odin pretty much and that's I
was gonna say aren't they all Odin guys
that's the whole the whole concept
behind Thor and all them is that we've
portrayed them as Gods but they're not
really Gods yeah you have like Odin and
you have vishna and you have all these
people to some degree is like Stargate
with the whole Egyptian alien thing
that's yeah that's exactly it that's
exactly it like DC has our own version
they're called the new gods and that's
dark side oron and all them and they
basically have replaced the old gods
okay so explain that to me because I've
heard I've heard the idea of the new
Gods but I thought that was like like a
super story line or something like that
it was like like Superman was one of the
new gods or something like that I don't
know the the the concept behind the DC
Universe is that at the very very edge
of the universe we have the source wall
and the source wall is what separates
every Universe and everything from each
other um and the source wall at one
point decided to kill because everyone
was trying to get to the source wall and
the theory is that if the gods can get
to the source wall they can rule all of
humanity that's what the anti-life
equation is so at some point the old
gods were completely destroyed and R and
gotten rid of by The Source wall and he
ushered in the the new gods and the new
gods are now on a quest to be that you
have the good New Gods that's oron and
all them and then you have the evil ones
like dark side who are trying to get the
anti-life equation the anti-life
equation is an equation that once you
use it and how you use it has always
been portrayed differently from putting
a mark on your head to just knowing it
to saying it everything has been changed
but once that has been used you get rid
of life in a person and by what what
what he means by getting rid of life is
their Free Will and choice to do what
they want yeah you don't live
anymore wow I know about that is because
of because the Superman or yeah no yeah
Justice League the cartoon covered the
source wall the anti life equation Dark
Side the new God new genesis uh all of
that ory everybody yep I mean that's
that's pretty let's see Marvel did
something similar to that like are you
guys familiar with the beyonder in the
Marvel Universe well most of the new
gods and stuff that was all created by
Jack Kirby way back in the day final
crisis was gr Morrison practically
removing he opened it by killing off all
of Jack Kirby's Creations yeah wow he
destroyed all the new gods they were all
killed and sent to Earth as punishment
yeah it was really weird yeah well and
uh and Marvel um I'm not very familiar
with him so I might so s might be able
to correct me here but you've got
molecule
yes and I don't know a lot about
molecule man but what I from what I
understand it's been years since I read
this from what I understand molecule man
gained his powers and it punched a hole
in the Multiverse mhm and you have like
the Multiverse which would be like you
know like this bit is that like the
super boy Prime punch I no no I mean it
just it just like tore hole basically in
like the Multiverse but you have like
this like the Multiverse is like this
big then you have like the Beyond verse
which is like everything beyond the
Multiverse and that's the Beyond the
that was the secret Wars definition of
the beyonder later they said that he was
actually a Cosmic Cube that gains
sension yeah but that was that was after
the um that was after the god what was
his name he used to be the editor and
chief he was one that wrote Secret Wars
that was the Joe damn it no um say like
he's pretty recent jimm shooter jimm
shooter there we go jimm shooter yeah
jimm shooter was R then they reconed
after Secret Wars Volume 2 I think or
Secret Wars Episode 2 I think it was
yeah um but real quick I want throw this
out there but just real quick because
everyone's asking me if I red guys I get
my comic books on Thursdays because the
local area up here gets them a day after
everyone else so I actually haven't read
anything so asking me questions about
the stuff that came out yesterday don't
know they're all like wasn't that used
in multiversity and did you read this
and I'm like no no I didn't it's right
here what's going on Ryan buddy mine
Ryan hit me up in the chat nice okay um
the beyonder later with the Illuminati
Bendis rcon in that the beyonder was
actually a mutant who was masquerading
in the inhuman city of tillan and
exposed himself to the Terrian Mists
okay and so it was a mutant inhuman okay
who then gained beyonder esque powers
and became the beyonder okay I couldn't
remember like the entire full back I
knew the beyonder was like this stupidly
super omnipotent and it was like three
he's been three different things and
none of them people and nobody likes any
of them yeah well that's but that's the
problem is you have like a character
who's just stupid powerful and just has
no real redeeming attributes in his
personality no so like nobody cares Noe
and I think Bendis wound up putting him
in the real world at the end of it oh
okay like like beond is like I'm out and
he leaves I had a really cool theory
that Unfortunately they didn't do but I
was on the Bendis board and I po and I
was like I think this is is what benis
is doing and benis is like that's really
cool no I didn't do
that it was in Illuminati they go to
like they're like okay we figured out
that the we oh in the Illuminati
miniseries took place right after secret
War and the team is like we need to deal
with the beyonder so this never happens
again and so the Illuminati go find the
beyonder and they give him a hard time
and they're and the beyonder is
at this point they they've established
he's limitlessly powerful and he can
influence things that they don't even
know how far-reaching it is and the
beyonder created like a little play
World of New York City and like Luke
Cage is there and Spider-Man's there and
like all the stuff's happening and
they're fighting each other like the
heroes are fighting each other and uh
he's talking to the
Illuminati and then the Hulk shows up
and punches through them like he punches
them and they're like they jump out of
the way and viandra goes oh I hadn't
planned that event and it was right
before World War Hulk interrupted all
the other stuff that was going on yeah
and I was like oh he just foreshadowed
World War Hulk like maybe all like Civil
War like House of M World War Hulk
they're all just the beyonder creating
these events happening like the beyonder
made like the like gave Scarlet Witch
the power to actually make House of M
happen the beyonder set the Hulk's ship
to go to war world and the beyonder like
made the ship explode and killed this
like sakar and his wife and [__] like
that the beyonder was in fact the reason
for all this other all the current
Marvel stories happening um God that
would have been such a damn good ending
right what they would just had to go
dealt with him and like nope and then at
the end of it they're like the uh he
goes to the real world like he they they
they photo stated like an image of Time
Square New York at that moment that they
were that they were writing the comic
and they put him there and he was like
where was I oh yes the world and the
implication was that the beyonder like
left the mar Universe came to the real
world and started screwing with things
there and I'm like that ties in with my
theory because now he's done he's done
creating Marvel events and now he's
going to come to the real world and like
make us invade Iraq and stuff like he's
going to make the real
you really Ed a lot of the evasion of
Iraq to the Beyond well you know like
something that like made no sense and
like why would we do that and it's like
be beyonder made it happen like you know
dude S I would take like take off dude
that would I thought that I was like I'm
clever dude if Ben had come out and said
that like at the end of New Avengers if
he had said like everything that's
transpired after like the secret Wars
with Jim shooter like this is all the
work of the beyonder that would have
been amazing yeah that would have been
like what that would have been so good
been their crisis that could have been
their way of being like well we got rid
of the Beyond so now the world's going
to reset to the time after Secret Wars
that could that could have been their
crisis that would have been really
really good yeah like oh Spider-Man
never got married the X-Men never like
ran into the Phoenix they could have
redone the Phoenix Saga oh so much could
have been done so much they could do
yeah but they didn't but they didn't d
kji ki's right man kenji's like sound
needs to write for Marvel you need to
write for Marvel man than Kenji uh would
be write to Marvel and tell them about
that if you happen to have the address
the Bendis let him know that s is
looking for a job so with Marvel he he
would like to he would like to be
employed by Marvel he's got some great
ideas for story lines involing Beyond
literally I live about 45 minutes away
from Marvel I will I will run papers I
don't
care so he gets you the job you're the
mail boy I mean I would take that job
Man Marvel HQ yeah Dan slot pretended to
be a student he lied on his uh what was
it his his intern application
and he became an intern for a school he
didn't go to and he made a bunch of
friends and then he they were like hey
what school do you go and like hey when
you turn 18 you can be you can work here
like it it's too bad you're in school
when you get out you can work here and
he goes oh I don't go to school I'm
actually like 19 and they were like what
and he's like I got you and they're like
oh that's a great story okay you can
stay like that'll never work again and
May and maybe we will actually check the
recommendations next time we we were
going to call people now yeah but um um
yeah God that would have been so to real
that that was the probably our craziest
tangent we've ever had that came out of
fut End
discussion and ended with s using the
Beyond to fix the Marvel
Universe man I I'm man that would have
been a damn good story that would have
been a damn good ending to the story
yeah I'm surprised like I'm surprised he
didn't take it I know so okay so so
basically we've established now access
is going to be awesome um from the looks
of things uh and if it isn't we'll be
very disappointed we're all hoping it's
not going to be like the original sin
situation Futures End is up in the air
like do we care Tiffany you're perfect
would is it no no no because you don't
buy DC right now that's true that's true
this is seeing a bunch of new number
ones with the tag features in gonna make
you go pick it
up there must be at least one DC
Superhero you enjoy if you go there and
see that book it says number they have
the new Batgirl costume yeah you know
what I mean like look when new 52 first
came out I initially gravitated
immediately towards Batwoman and then s
explained to me that they didn't really
reset that so I was like oh crap now I
got to go back and read all this there's
a few of them they didn't reset yeah
they didn't that one um so I mean yeah a
number one sometimes will draw me to it
I mean the problem I have with DC is is
because of the fact that um their
characters tend to be a little more
lofty in Heights and maybe not as
grounded in reality I sometimes find
them them a little hard to approach now
with my background in animated cartoons
and my love of like you know Batman
animated series and Superman and Justice
League like I would probably give them a
chance but like I don't know if it would
make a reader out of me especially if
we're dealing with time drums and then I
feel like I have to know what happened
beforehand if they're referencing any
you know what I mean like right yeah it
just seems like I'm coming into the
middle the very beginning of a mess and
I don't necessarily want to clean it up
that's that I imagine is probably the
the biggest issue and even then like you
know with like like DC or Marvel if if
right now you went out and bought a
bunch of number ones and then in three
years you see new number ones then I
imagine the first question would be like
didn't they just have a bunch of number
ones like didn't we just do that it
would make me feel a little betrayed
like Oh I thought I thought you like
we're doing something special just for
new readers and now it's like well no I
mean like we have new readers see we get
yeah let's get I I got a great example
of one thing and maybe s s did you read
Teen Titans before no here's a great
example example of them betraying the
readers so Team Titans had a great run
before it went 30 something issues we
had a beginning a middle an end a whole
story arc everything in the new 52 in
the new 52 it was great they finished
the story arc and they said we're doing
it again yep and we now have Team Titans
number two now what irritates me this
isn't like The Suicide Squad reboot
where we pretty much changed out most of
the team except Harley Quinn and
Deadshot yeah right this is the same
team
Titans this is literally the same
team yeah I I was just we re we reviewed
the new the first one like last like two
weeks ago as Teen Titans number one for
off the rack and I was like this is the
second reboot of the Teen Titans right
from the new 52 and they're like why and
I'm like I don't
know there was no reason the story arc
ended great if you wanted to reboot the
book how about we change up the team a
little the only difference is super boy
is not on it because he
died I mean dude if you want to see a
frustration when it comes to reading
stories man go read power pack like
power pack is power pack is is I read
the original Power Pack like power
Pack's special yeah like old school yeah
back in the day power pack with like the
Unicorn or the horse or whatever his
name was was what was he he was like a
chameleon or something like that I don't
remember the Unicorn I just remember
like the team and like the the random
team ups they tried to force in because
they weren't selling well like it was
awful it's like a bunch of like toddlers
basically like superpowers yeah it's
eight or nine year olds being
superheroes that's basically it like
it's it's that
works yeah well I I
imagine that down the road like a couple
months if Marvel keeps rebooting every
like 12 issues or something it's just
going to be a nightmare for
collectors like it that don't pick up
like a weekly or a monthly comic
like okay this is Iron Man issue number
six why are there like 12 different
covers oh wait that's because this is
issue number six from like January
whereas this is issue number six from
from last
November it's yeah it's going to get
really confusing for people I'm sure it
already want to pick up back issues yeah
yeah no it is and actually I used to
collect number ones and if a new number
one came out I'd always get it and I've
actually told my pull my comic shop just
stop pulling them because I can't afford
10 new number ones every month just yeah
not of I'm getting my current books
that's why that's why I like Marvel so
much because you know again back to
Richard Ryder if if all you really want
to do is understand Richard Ryder when
he returns if you want to play catchup
there's three stories you need to read
the first one is where Richard Ryder
gains his powers the second one is
Richard Ryder during Annihilation when
all the when the entire novacore dies
and the third one is a Thanos imperative
and that'll catch you up on everything
you need to know about Richard Ryder
there's three stories that's it and then
you can pick up Richard Ryder I I assume
they're going to do like a Marvel Now
Richard Ryder number one well they
probably won't even need you probably
won't even need to pick up the the new
Richard Ryder the old Richard ryer
they'll probably explain majority of it
because what I think I do like about
Marvel that they don't do in DC is every
Marvel book has that little prequel
thing at the beginning here's what you
missed if you haven't in Reading yeah
really important thing yeah I I rely on
that heavily yeah no oh yeah no because
half the books I'm reading like like the
incursions I read when it launched I
jumped in like 12 issues late and the
explanation Mage caught me up enough
that I understood what was going on I
was good to go I didn't need to go
looking for 12 other issues yeah do you
think that they put more emphasis on the
like putting the story arc title on the
books and numbering those and leaving
the run just keep going if they're not
rebooting a whole universe that that
would work better and make it less
invalid what they've done like three
years ago for example with the new 52
like instead of renumbering the number
ones for this upcoming Futures End Arc
if they just were like we're just going
to call it Futures End and like we're
going to make that more prevalent on the
cover so that you understand this is a
good jumping off point but we're going
to leave our numbers regular like
wouldn't that satisfy both like the what
I think they should do with the way the
way the the way the pretty much the
entertainment industry has become now is
we need to go away go and they're kind
of going in this direction now but I
think they're going a little too crazy
with it um Teen Titans the reboot that
we should be doing comic series almost
as Seasons now yeah that's how they
should be treating yeah and not not on a
willy-nilly oh we're going to do Gambit
number one Magneto number one and all
these different number ones and then
just maybe they'll work out like
legitimately Gambit's going to have one
through eight this is volume 29 you know
Gambit X Gambit awesome Gambit whatever
you want to call it and then we'll just
do another book in a minute in a minute
right as soon as that's done with a new
story arc and that would make it so easy
to understand where you're jumping off
point is because one thing that I've ran
into with a lot of people and we had
discussed this a few uh episodes back of
the podcast um is when forever evil
ended I was telling people the issue 31
is a great starting point for DC now
because it's all new stories but I still
have to tell you 31 you know yeah yeah
yeah and that's and Marvel used to be
really bad about that back in the day
like s knows about this but back when
they used to have like Strange Tales all
that kind of stuff like they numbered it
up to 150 something or 160 something
with Doctor Strange and then all of a
sudden it was like Doctor Strange issue
number 100 something and you were like
what happened the last 100 issues and it
those are all Strange Tales so people
were like oh okay okay I understand so
Marvel is getting better about that but
the problem again is is if you sit down
and if you know if I say hey check out
Magneto number one you're gonna be like
okay I mean I guess we get the backstory
of Magneto but what happened to like all
the other stories that Magneto was
involved in and you start from there you
know and all that kind stuff and that's
what causes the problem I think I think
the old comic mentality is the bigger
the number the bigger the pedigree um
you know Spider-Man's got 600 issues you
know you can trust Spider-Man cuz he's
been here for 600 issues while the new
mentality for comic books is a number
one's going to sell this book everyone
knows that they can jump in here even
even if you don't know Magneto's history
you know that at least the core story
arc is going to be one through whatever
we go to yeah but but I'm sorry go ahead
go ahead
oh go ahead go ahead go ahead I will I
will sit here and be silent go ahead oh
I was to say I'd love to see their sales
projections after the number one to see
how many people they retain after
selling a number like making such a big
deal about here are my number ones all
right well how many people did you
retain to number two and I mean
literally retain not who just picked up
the number two because they missed the
number one I mean literally who bought
number one and then went out was like
when two comes out I'm getting two and
then three and then they're on down like
to see what the diminishing returns are
for that yeah it's it's it's it's an
interesting circumstance because like
God knows like I tried to turn my
girlfriend on to comic books and she was
like
no like that's that's that's shit's not
happening because it's a daunting task I
mean if I say hey let's you know do you
want to check out Spider-Man like she's
going to look I'm going to say okay
here's the most recent issue of
Spider-Man like Spider-Man number one or
whatever it is before that it's
Spider-Man number 61 or something and
like if you're not a constant comic book
reader then God knows that when you sit
down and you try to read from a
character and you try to pick up with
the old stuff as well as a new stuff you
just end up in this great big huge
convoluted complicated world and you
don't know where to go so number ones
are cool but the problem with a person
sitting down and saying okay let's read
issue number one they want to know about
the old stuff even if they never really
read it like they want to know about the
old stories of Magneto like why is it
that Magneto is so popular now that
we're even doing a Magneto because this
is the first Standalone Magneto series
that I've ever heard of in Marvel Comics
really good though yeah I saw your uh
your your back issues I think way yeah
or off the rack way back when with
Magneto number one you guys were saying
it was amazing which I check it out but
you know what I think it is though I
think they would rather pull someone in
with Magneto one and you read it and go
wow this guy's cool I want to know the
history and then you go look for the
trades than trying to convince someone
to go get Magneto number 5508 or go get
Magneto who's got a story arc inside of
uncanny Avengers for the next three
issues you yeah exactly right it's
interesting you mentioned the trades
because that's how he would give me
Spider-Man books in in trades because
like I don't to worry about the number
then like the book will explain it to me
and that's all he needs to know and here
it is and I read the Spider-Man story
and there we go and then you know what's
next or what came before if I care but
like and that's that's why I actually
wait for the hard covers and the trades
to come out because yeah I don't I don't
need to bother like if I don't have
money or I don't feel like going to the
comic store or something like every
Wednesday for example why would you
not why would you not visit your local
B&M you you should be going to the
bricking Border no of course like I know
the trades does hurt so the industry to
some degree because you know if there's
a new book out there I know that they
won't know that anyone has any interest
in it until after it's already cancelled
yeah also I'll buy the trade on Amazon
for $3 instead of $15 and so I won't
spend like the $100 for the 13 issues or
whatever like have you seen the latest
Trend though um they used to do it a
little bit but now they're doing a lot
more but they're releasing straight to
trade B graphic novels now that's great
way to go I think it's where it's going
I mean what Dave does makes the most
sense to me like Dave sits down and
waits until like the entire series is
finished and says okay I'll buy the
Omnibus now like I'm not gonna
buy of do the same thing filtering out
it helps filtering out the crappy story
lines too like if something's not
important then I haven't invested $520
in it yeah I mean at that point it just
comes down to you know like the elitist
thing like I have the Omnibus well I
have all the trades like okay well you
just spent hundred extra dollars you
didn't need to so yeah exactly I have
all the
individuals XL as you didn't need to
Dave well no not not da I'm talking
about you Benny I have the omnus what
are you talking about yeah I know I'm
I'm just saying like I have the issues
this is even more money for Less info
that's that's what we're
saying but yeah no that's cuz I'm
impatient and I want to know what's
going to
happen I don't want to wait five months
I'll forget the whole storyline even
happened you know no I've been
experiencing that getting into Saga now
I'm like I hate this I hate it so much
having to wait like usually everything I
get from is in a trade or it's all over
I'm like great now waiting month to
month I wait for the trade I can't do
that I cannot do that as a weekly
release or monthly release because also
the guy who writes Saga is really lazy
and misses that deadline a lot yeah yeah
Indie books are terrible for for being
like delayed Printing and yeah it's
killing me but I still buy it
yeah well another thing is like the the
print shops don't have the budgets that
Marvel does to print a a hard cover book
a month after the story Line's done they
need like three or four months to print
a hard cover after the story Line's done
because it takes them a lot more time I
mean it's just one of those interesting
things you know like it's it's it's some
of the cooler things that you just don't
get caught up on when you pick up the
new number ones like if I say what do
you know about the fact that Magneto is
actually not as old as he seems like he
is yeah was deaged at one point in time
wait what yeah Magneto was deaged at one
there was some villain that he fought
was it Joseph well he he became Joseph
oh yeah no no no there was one point
where he fought a villain who made him
younger oh yeah yeah but that was that
was their way of making him that that
seems like a really good villain to
fight make you
young pick aight oh I'm Gonna Make You
younger old man I I'm feeling I'm
feeling a bit puckish I like it to make
me younger can we you let's F just walk
up and punch him in the face yeah what's
going on [__] yeah all right I I
think we're on a thousand one crazy
tangents and we've now exceeded the
longest podcast we've ever done where
where are we at right now like two hours
it'll be 240 by the time we wrap up
minutes okay well I guess we'll put off
Inhumans yet again for another time oh
no no I'll cover this because I had AR I
had legitimate ARG yeah I I can do it I
because I had an legitimate argument
with Dave and Rob and Rob thought I was
yelling at him and then he yelled at me
and we got a huge ass argument
Rob books at me I threw books at Rob
Dave was like Mommy and Daddy are
fighting it was
funny and S was just like what is going
on like hey guys what's
up um they wanted to talk about this I'm
gonna tell you Vin Diesel said in
passing that Marvel thinks he may be
inhuman by giving him two roles due to
this everyone thinks that vend diesel
was going to be blackball dis it's
confirmed it is confirmed that vend was
going to be blackbolt because he said
that he might have the chance to do it
well no that's not confirmation of
anything yeah hey Rob I might be
Superman in the next Batman Superman
movie well that's awesome man you like
you need like rob a rob a money truck
and just give us all the money I'm sure
they must be really Slim on the budget
for that next
movie smaller budget I think I think the
Vin Diesel can make a pretty effective
blackbolt I agree yes I agree I'm sure
and like you know the fact that he loves
nerdy things yeah helps like does help
significantly so like maybe the fact
that he chose those words specifically
oh he did that on Pur you know what I
mean like maybe it's not that he's
blackbolt but he could be any he's gonna
be lockjaw he's gonna be the voice of
lockjaw that would be so awesome a
teleporting dog so so here here's the
thing though
is I think it's only fair of Marvel to
offer him a better role than Groot as
well because only saying I am Groot and
not being able to convey much of any
facial expressions
either you know different man like
blackbolt never talks so if he does play
back blackbolt it would have to be like
whoever that plays Medusa would have to
be like the best actress ever because
she interprets everything he says but
another you know what though they could
easily do an inter monologue with him
but secondly I guarantee you the Groot
thing was like a side thing I think he
was probably signed on to do his
Inhumans role which is probably dude
Benny that is such a good point if if
they had Vin Diesel playing blackbolt
and he does inner monologue the whole
time I would point to pitch black
because his inter modock at the
beginning of that movie was so
amazing God it was so good and another
thing is if he doesn't talk at all that
takes a great amount of skill to to
convey a performance with just your face
yeah that says a lot about your acting
well that's what you do with Groo they
they motion cap his face onto the giant
wood tree thing yeah yeah
but say I feel like Disney should
purchase the Ric franchise and just
throw him into the Guardians of the
Galaxy Universe man that would be so
around like two knives and just just run
into him him and draxx are comparing
knives
bigger be like $30 to buy from him right
I mean I mean I want to see that I want
to see like rck versus Thanos I want to
see who would win such a beastly fight
rck versus Thanos movie confirmed guys
you've heard it here so I'm I'm just
proving my point because they said that
we'd have plenty to talk about we're now
discussing Ric versus the versus Thanos
we're not even discussing Black Bolt in
humans announcement anymore it's true
we're trying to wrap it up Benny we're
trying to wrap it up it is a waste of a
great voice to make him Black Bolt it
really I mean in all no except for the
one thing he
says the one thing he says it'll be
really he's going to say one thing it'll
be no yes or fudge off scream at him I
mean I would love to see how Marvel
would do that with blackbolt just
screaming at somebody like would I mean
it'd be curious like are they going to
use like the new blackbolt and like
where he can scream and annihilate
planets or is it just going to be like
the old blackbolt where he screams and
just knocks people unconscious you know
or something I mean either way though it
it it'd be it'd be pretty interesting
but anyway we need to wrap this up so um
I need to get some sleep what does
everybody have going on for the next uh
next week or so I don't uh well we are
going to be exhibiting at the Garden
State comic Fest this Saturday on August
23rd at the Morristown Hiatt uh we'll be
having a booth there we will be uh doing
a live back issues at uh 11:00 a.m.
hopefully going to be filming it but you
know there's uh who knows what might
happen so I want to say that just in
case people want to go and you
know uh so we'll be doing that and uh
we're shooting off the rack back issues
busted tonight I actually have to leave
in 15 minutes to do that so I timed the
ending of this one well you did so we're
doing that and uh our fan voted episode
of back issues came out today which was
siege oh I lost God yeah I'm sorry but
you know what we may do Secret War
today Siege was such a great story yeah
Deadpool
core I'll put it on my list man I
promise Deadpool core I just love the
way he's doing it like he whispers over
to Sou like sitting next to camera I can
see you dead core you you actually
appear nobody but s can hear me hey
what's going on Rob's unbelievable huh
internet magic man it's internet magic
you can see people they talk you can
hear it's
crazy house um well is a video one thing
for one thing I have three new videos
out on my channel because I went from
being completely dry as a desert to
completely like downpouring torrent in
terms of of of the videos I'm releasing
so uh I did the Ice Bucket Challenge
Benny challenged me to that uh and I
also have Civil War Avengers and
Spider-Man out uh I'm going to continue
that with some I guess less important
books to collect but I'm going to make
videos on them anyways because it that
makes a complete collection I'm going to
do probably Fantastic 4 and front lines
this this coming
week and and Robert over here uh feels
like front lines was was really good and
I have to agree but front lines was
amazing yeah it was
whatever don't even start civil war
front lines was so good no it was it was
it was a good book to read but it didn't
have a lot of weight on the story as a
whole it wasn't supposed to which is
supposed to be from the perspective of
journalists exactly that cool and then
there was a giant Howard the Duck like
issue at the back of it which totally
made the collection for Me Howard the
Duck man what a goofy ass character all
right um I've got I'm I've been
postponing it for a while but I think
I'm GNA probably put out Avenger
Avengers disassembled in Deadpool for my
next two videos um and then we're doing
a new series over on the channel now uh
Indie books that comes out every Monday
is because nobody here covers Indie
books so I got to do it yeah we would do
it but nobody freaking watches them no
I'm working on that everybody everybody
so elst man it's all positive comments
from like the 10 people that watched it
yeah not only that but like I I we used
to I really wanted to do at least one
issue I wanted to do one episode a week
of off the rack where we do an indie
book we would blast it out to the Indie
creators like hey man we're doing a
review of your book we're promoting it
no response no care across the board
whether they were unpublished people or
like Warren Ellis no one gave a crap I
was like well then you know what screw
you independent books we'll just do
Aquaman it'll be aqua
Show apparently people love
Aquaman um well uh this actually creates
some cool stuff um of course we're going
to do we're going to finish up Infinity
gaet we're going to do like lead up so
we'll have the Living Tribunal up soon
um if you guys want to know about all
the other Cosmic entities eternity and
the Watchers and stuff like that you can
watch The Cosmic entities video um and
then we'll do the uh Thanos Quest then
The Infinity Gauntlet and uh uh Warlock
and the infinity watch but because
Vinny's going to be doing the Avengers
just a simple story line that will lead
us into the house of M which is that I
will do finally which I will I will do a
video wait you love this story so much
I've been waiting love the house love
the house of him so
much if I hit your ride on that I mean
have had and do my house of M collection
when you guys house of Shaban yeah also
Rob we were debating how to do this but
but I'm gonna throw this out there now
but with original sin wrapping up next
month uh Rob is actually G to do a
current storyline explanation and I'm
going to do the cliffnotes version yes I
finally convinced Rob to talk about
something he actually reads yes that's
the whole point of moving forward with
the House of M that's the whole reason
why we're doing House of M because we're
going to start with the House of M and
move forward and get into actually like
some current [__] so we uh we did Civil
War we did House of M that'll lead us
into dark rain The Siege all that kind
of stuff and then we'll actually get
into like we actually get into the
Marvel Now stuff and we'll get the hell
out of the
1980s
way further to like the 70s and the 60s
maybe the first Fantastic Four oh we're
go all the way back to timely Comics man
we're going to go back to funny
comics just wanted to go on record and
say House of M months ago so uh you can
always hey hey Rob you need to do a
peanuts explained oh yeah Peanuts
Charlie Brown
explained Snoopy you just totally did
told me what I'm doing for April fools
Next
Year Charlie
Brown my Halloween episode is Marvel
Zombies from under oh dude I have Marvel
Zombies done well yeah whatever I'm
doing it Halloween I mean I have some of
Marvel Marvel I don't have like the full
Marvel Zombies all of it I'm doing all
of it the I have I have the 12200 page
on this for Marvel Zombies I might doen
you
yeah oh good your Omnibus is fine yeah
man that'd be the way to do it all right
well uh with that being said if we're
all uh if we're all wrapped up I think I
speak for everybody here when I say that
Tiffany definitely needs to come back
for the thank you so much I had you good
time we loved having you on here and uh
yeah so we're we're two hours and 40 six
minutes this my God long episode ever
I'm TOA this no I'm going to disclaim
this real quick right now this probably
won't happen every week probably not
guys I have to say this though we do
have 50 people watching this yeah you
guys are amazing you've been here the
whole time but only 23 of you liked this
so yeah what is what all right I'm
suffering through it I don't
care oh man
all right well uh yeah so I guess we're
going to call it a night yeah support
your local com book store and don't buy
features in so they
stop later on
guys